[MUSIC PLAYING]
MODERATOR: I believe too
few serious scholars are
studying the social
impact of computers,
the way they affect us
as individuals in groups
and in society at large,
as we learn, as we work,
and even as we play.
Now, that's strange to me.
Because here we have the
most powerful tool mankind
has ever known.
And we've hardly begun to
analyze how it is affecting us,
let alone how it is
shaping us and how
we can shape it so
that we get what
we want in the way of affects.
Lee Sproull is one of
those few individuals who
has devoted her entire
professional life
to this all-important area.
After 15 years as a professor
of social sciences at CMU,
she's now a professor
of Management
at Boston University.
And she's published seven
books and many research papers
in this area.
And it's a special
pleasure for me
to have someone address this key
topic, someone who has devoted
her entire life to it.
Thank you, Lee.
SPROULL: I feel so old.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm not a computer
science pioneer.
I hope that was at least
implicit in what Andy said.
Although some of my best
friends certainly are.
[LAUGHTER]
For the past 25
years, I have been
pleased and privileged
to be an observer
of the community making
parts of Bush's vision real.
When Doug was talking yesterday
about how human systems
and computer tools need
to evolve together,
I was actually reminded of
one of my early experiences
as a user of this
technology in 1977.
I'm trained as a sociologist.
My doctoral dissertation
had absolutely nothing
to do with computing.
But I typed it on an Alto
computer at Xerox PARC.
I printed the final
document on EARS.
And I think there may be a
few people in this room who
know about EARS, one of the
earliest laser printers.
I collected the signatures
on the signature page
of my dissertation.
I took my dissertation
to the registrar's office
at Stanford to be
certified, bound, blessed,
whatever it is that
happens to these things.
Now, this was in the days when
the production requirements
for dissertations were
extremely stringent.
The requirements
specified a certain kind
of rag paper, black carbon
ribbon, no erasures.
So I handed in my thesis,
my laser-printed thesis.
The dragon lady in
the registrar's office
flipped through the pages, ran
her fingers over the words,
fixed me with a steely eye, and
said, you can't turn this in.
It isn't the original.
[LAUGHTER]
I was highly evolved.
My computing tools were
highly evolved for that time.
But the social system in
which I was doing my work
had a ways to go.
Still true today.
I'm delighted to be here to
celebrate the technology vision
that we are all
pleased to honor.
Actually though, mostly
what I want to do
is talk about the human vision
or models of human beings
that are associated with
Bush's technology vision,
and also other visions that
we're hearing about today.
Every technology vision
that really captures
people's imagination
is accompanied
by a view of human beings using
the technology, who they are,
what they do, how their
lives are changed,
improved, we hope,
by the technology.
The human vision
that is associated
with the memex with
Bush's paper is a view
of a person working alone.
Could I have the
first slide, please?
Working alone, not doing
housework or manual labor,
but doing intellectual work.
The technology, of
course, is envisioned
to support that solo work,
to make it more productive,
to make it even more creative.
Now, in Bush's paper, we have
evoked the view of the scholar,
seated at a wonderful desk,
interacting with the world
scientific literature, alone.
Licklider, in his 1960 paper,
"Man, Machine, Symbiosis,"
evokes a view of the
scientist or an engineer
solving problems more
productively with a machine
doing the clerical and
mechanical activities.
The scientist or engineer
is alone with the machine.
Alan Kay evokes a view of a
person of any age, especially
a child, interacting
with a dynamic medium
for creative
thought, a Dynabook,
to work and play more
productively and creatively,
alone.
Now, of course, we have to note
that Doug Engelbart has always
been the exception
to this fairly
common view of the
human being associated
with the personal computer.
As early as 1968, of course, he
was describing computer support
for people working together,
sharing files, working
in real-time meetings.
This technology vision of
personal computing, of course,
is extraordinarily important,
extraordinarily worthwhile.
There's a whole lot
more to be done,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
But science, and
Bush, after all,
was speaking about the
scientific community.
Science and most
other productive work
in modern society is
inherently a social enterprise.
Could I have the
next slide, please?
Lick was an empiricist, and
therefore dear to my heart.
He reported real data
in his 1960 paper.
He reported, in fact, that
85% of his thinking time
was devoted to clerical
or mechanical activities--
searching, calculating,
plotting, transforming.
He used his data
on human behavior--
data on himself, but still,
data on human behavior--
to justify his
technology vision.
What he didn't
point out though, is
that while 85% of
his thinking time
was devoted to clerical
or mechanical activities,
probably only 15% of his
day was devoted to thinking.
The rest was probably
spent in meetings.
[LAUGHTER]
You've been there?
Face-to-face interaction
with other human beings--
I don't mean only formal
meetings, conferences,
symposia.
Hallway conversations
count, as well.
There have been many,
many time allocation
studies of people working in
a variety of fields, including
scientists-- bench scientists,
technical supervisors
and managers, people across
all of these studies, all
of this kind of work--
spend between 50% to 85%
of their day in meetings.
And in addition to that,
they spend some fraction
of their alone time
recovering from meetings.
I mean during
followup work, but I
guess there's other
kinds of recovery, too.
Let me give you just some
more evidence and reminders
of something that we
all know very well,
that science is a
social enterprise,
one indicator of growth
in team size over time.
It took two people to
build the first airplane.
It took 7,302 people to
build the Boeing 777.
Author lists for
papers and journals
have certainly been
growing over the years.
In the past 40 years,
the mean number
of authors for papers published
in scientific journals
across all disciplines
has doubled.
The mean number of
authors per paper in 1955
was 1.8, in 1994 was 3.5.
Last year, in '94, there
were more than 700 papers
published in scientific
journals that had more than 50,
5-0, authors listed
on the title page.
The, I think, record
so far, last year,
the two papers announcing the
discovery of the top quark
last year, each listed over
400 authors on the title page.
Now, even in academic
computer science--
computer science is not known
as a big science field--
the mean size of work
teams is increasing.
If you look at the
proceedings of SIGGRAPH,
the computer
graphics conference,
the mean number of authors
per paper at SigGraph in 1975
was 1.7.
In '94, it was 2.4.
If you look at the ACM
Computer Chess Championship,
the mean number of
people associated
with the winning program
from '74 to '84 was two.
The mean number associated
with the winning program
from '85 to '94 was 3.8.
These are fairly formal
indicators of the fact
that science is not
a solo enterprise.
Here's a livelier one.
This is from Lewis
Thomas's description
of the marine
biological laboratory
at Woods Hole, a
human institution
that, as Lewis Thomas says, is
possessed of a life of its own,
with an extraordinary influence
on the growth and development
of biologic science.
Lewis Thomas suggests
that, to learn more
about the marine
biological laboratory,
you might begin at Stony Beach.
He says, "It's the
most minor of beaches,
hardly big enough
for a committee,
but close enough
to the laboratories
so that the investigators
can walk down
for a sandwich lunch with their
children on sunny weekdays.
On weekends in hot
midsummer, it is so crowded
that one must pick
one's way on tiptoe
to find a hunching place.
But there is always a lot
of standing up anyway.
Biologists seem to prefer
standing on beaches talking
at each other,
gesturing to indicate
the way things are assembled,
bending down to draw diagrams
in the sand.
By the end of the day,
the sand is criss-crossed
with a mesh of
ordinance, abscesses,
curves to account for
everything in nature.
You can hear the sound from
the beach at a distance
before you see the people.
It is that most extraordinary
noise, half shout, half song,
made by confluent,
simultaneously
raised human voices explaining
things to each other."
Now that's what
science is about.
Personal computing,
fortunately, has
evolved to allow
interpersonal communication,
to allow people to explain
things to each other,
to talk with each
other using computers.
Could I have the
next slide, please.
You might just do a
little thought experiment.
What would the
world be like today
if there were 100 million
personal computers
and no interactive
communication,
no ability to contact
people or create and sustain
human relationships with other
people through these machines?
Actually, I'm not sure we
would be having this meeting.
And I don't mean just,
we wouldn't have gotten
the logistics of it organized.
I'm not so sure we would
be here to celebrate
the way the vision has
come to be played out.
Of course, we shouldn't
feel sorry for Bush
that he didn't predict
the power or importance
of interpersonal
communication in the context
of his technology vision.
He's in good company.
Not only the history of
personal computing, but even
the history of
computer communications
features technologists
who underestimated
the lure and importance of
human communication using
this technology.
Everyone in this room is
familiar with the ARPANET
and email story.
In fact, some of the
people in this room
were the heroes or villains
or something in that story.
But the conventional
wisdom, anyway,
has it that the ARPANET was
conceived to link computers.
And of course, we all know
it turned out to link people,
too, initially through
email, distribution lists,
and bulletin boards
populated by members
of the same intellectual
community, who
were housed in a small
number of universities,
industrial labs, a
fairly homogeneous bunch
of folks, truth to tell.
Although they might not be
pleased to hear me say that.
More recently, as internet
access has soared,
the human links have been
formed through mechanisms,
like newsgroups or
usenet groups, that
are populated by
people who may have
absolutely nothing
in common with one
another except for internet
access and a shared interest
in the topic of the
particular group.
Commercial electronic
services providers,
like CompuServe
and Prodigy, also
didn't anticipate the importance
of the human communication
services, like
email, chat rooms.
Now, scientists certainly don't
just process information alone
in their offices.
Moreover, they don't
just communicate either,
generically.
They do these things
within social contexts.
That is, through multiple
ongoing relationships
with other people
and organizations.
I must say, I have been struck
by the serious observation made
by all the speakers thus far
that people are important
and social issues are important.
And obviously, I'm glad to
hear the speakers say that.
But there's a sort of
funny gap between how
the previous speakers talk about
people-- by which they mean
individual human beings
who speak into a microphone
or type with fingers
on keys or whatever--
and society, which is big
forces that are good or evil
or something, but they're huge.
There's a very large middle
ground that's very important.
And it's the middle ground where
most of the productive work
gets done in society, through
multiple ongoing relationships
with people in organizations.
Could I have the next one?
Each relationship, every one of
them, is structured by roles.
Roles have formal
responsibilities
and obligations
associated with them,
norms, accepted
rules for behavior.
Each relationship is shaped
through reciprocated action
of people working together.
Each relationship is
sustained through trust--
trust, by the way, doesn't
have to mean liking--
but sustained through trust,
obligation, and affiliation.
Now, people may complain
that they spend too much time
in meetings, often because
meetings aren't always
an efficient information
exchange mechanism.
But information exchange
isn't the only reason
for going to a meeting
or for participating
in an ongoing social context.
People like to talk
with other people.
People go to a workshop, even
when the papers are online.
Showing up signifies the
importance of the occasion
and the importance
of the community.
Let me give you an example
of a scientist doing
productive work through
multiple ongoing relationships.
And by the way, I
apologize for the sort
of wishy-washy
relationship word.
I couldn't figure out a
nice, crisp alternative,
so we're going to
have to go with it.
Think of a scientist at the
weekly meeting of his research
group who's critiquing the
research presentation of one
of his doctoral students.
This scientist is
simultaneously helping
to create new scientific
knowledge, perhaps describing
additional analyses that the
student could do in order
to refute the claims
made by a competing lab,
in addition,
reminding the student
to verify the analytic
techniques he's just been
describing with the new postdoc,
who has recently arrived
from a colleague's lab where
these techniques were first
developed.
That's one thing
that the scientist
is doing, helping to create
new scientific knowledge.
At the same time, the scientist
is training the next generation
of scientists through suggesting
the additional analyses,
through, perhaps, critiquing the
format of the student's slides,
through asking the
student to present
his results in the professor's
graduate survey course,
helping to create new
scientific knowledge,
training the next
generation of scientists,
deciding which of
his colleagues labs
to recommend as a good postdoc
placement for the student
when he finishes his thesis,
deciding which journal
to submit the
student's research to,
and remembering that he still
owes the editor of that journal
reviews on three papers.
Thinking about how
these results are
going to affect the next round
of studies, and deciding he's
going to have to apply for new
funds sooner than he had hoped,
realizing that he's
going to have to say yes
to the provost's request that
he chair the university task
force on graduate
education, if he's
going to have any hope
of getting the provost
to approve his request
for additional lab space.
Now, the manifest
task, when we're
thinking about this scientist,
the scientist's manifest task
is to critique a
research project.
But all of the other tasks
are equally necessary to being
a productive scientist.
They all entail information
processing, absolutely.
But each of these
information processing tasks
is embedded in a
particular social context,
a particular social
structure of reciprocal human
interdependence, a structure
that's sustained through trust,
obligation, and affiliation.
Furthermore, the contexts
the scientist is operating in
simultaneously operate
at different levels
of social aggregation.
Let me see if I can explain a
little bit what I mean by that.
Could I have the
next one, please.
The social enterprise
of science operates
at three levels of aggregation.
At the institutional level,
we have the human conventions
and organizations that
certify knowledge and allocate
resources.
We have the Nobel
Prize committees.
We have the scientific
journals with their editors
and editorial boards.
We have the research
funding agencies.
At the middle range, we have
the distributed colleagues
and competitors working
in a single area.
These play themselves out in
conferences, summer studies,
postdoc exchanges,
pre-print mailing lists.
The third level of
aggregation is the close
in level, the day-to-day
interaction with colleagues
and students.
This is the place,
this is the level
of aggregation, where
the apparatus is built,
where the measurements
are taken,
where results are initially
puzzled over and discussed,
and where the next
generation is socialized.
This is also the place where,
as some people would say,
if you don't have to get on
an airplane to go somewhere,
this is where you go,
the close in level.
The productive scientist
has to work simultaneously
at all three levels
of aggregation
and has to process information
and manage relationships
at all three levels.
So what can we say about
what computer support
for interdependent
actors looks like today?
What are the systems
and applications that
acknowledge interdependence?
Next slide.
I think the big success stories
are electronic mail and file
transfer.
I don't know if there's
anyone in this room who
would think they're
glamorous or represent
research frontiers for today.
But they certainly,
in terms of numbers
of people who use them to
get productive work done,
are the success stories,
unstructured general tools.
People can and do use them
in any social context--
well, probably not yet
to the Nobel committees,
but in most other
social contexts.
They require very little social
and cognitive overhead to use.
But of course, they're just
the beginning of what we need.
What are people
working on today?
I feel a bit audacious
telling this audience
about what computer
scientists are doing today.
But I think some of
these kinds of work
are not ones that would be
particularly visible or perhaps
even particularly
interesting to you, so let
me just say a very brief word.
At the other end of the
spectrum from unstructured email
and file transfer is
workflow, something
that, unfortunately,
business organizations
are quite enamored of today.
I don't want to dwell
on it, but it does
acknowledge interdependence.
It does things, like
attempts to automate things,
like administrative processes,
like travel requests
or payroll or some
business processes,
like approving
loan applications.
It's sort of a transaction
processing thing.
The focus is on the flow
of transaction tasks
across processors.
Some of the processors
may be human beings.
But the focus
isn't at all on all
of an individual human
being's responsibilities,
obligations, and tasks
as they're structured
in roles in an organization.
Another kind of work that a
bit of which is going on today,
there is something called
CSCW, which stands for computer
supported co-operative work.
And there is
groupware, allegedly
support for people doing
intellectual tasks.
CSCW, the acronym, was
created, I think, in 1986.
So this is certainly not an
old and venerable subfield.
But at any event,
some of the examples
of things that
people are working on
include working with shared
files, shared design spaces,
shared document editors, group
awareness tools, group meeting
rooms, to support
face-to-face meetings
or geographically
distributed meetings.
Now typically, in
much of this work,
the focus is on a small group.
I suspect a part of the reason
is it's sort of hard enough
to get the technology to work
for a small number of people.
I'm not clear that people
working in this area
believe that the small group
is the only useful or important
level at which people do work.
But at any event, much
of the work going on now
focuses on groups from
size, say, two to 10.
Also, much of this work
takes a single task focus.
For instance, there's
work on the task
of collaborative design.
There's work on the task of
brainstorming in meetings.
These applications are
often highly structured.
They may force people
to state assumptions
or to specify commitments and
to state their binary choices.
You're either in a meeting
room or you're not.
You're either present for the
video conference or you're not.
You're either explicitly making
a commitment or you're not.
I think that computer support
for the productive scientist,
who doesn't just
process information
but who works through
relationships with other people
and organizations, needs to
have a whole different flavor.
Could I have the
next slide, please?
It shouldn't just support
a task, a manifest task.
Because the
scientist, of course,
is doing multiple different
tasks simultaneously,
only one of which
is the manifest one.
It should not just
support a group,
because the scientist
is simultaneously
participating in multiple
groups at different levels
of social aggregation.
So what should this
computer support do?
It should support
the scientist who
works in multiple
groups simultaneously,
who works at different
levels of social aggregation
simultaneously.
It should move
with the scientist
as he or she physically and
cognitively moves from group
to group throughout the day.
And it should
allow the scientist
to map his information
environment
to his social contexts, not to
arbitrary physical locations
like a meeting room or
temporal constraints.
Now, since I'm not
a technologist,
it would be extraordinarily
silly for me to tell you
what the technology
should look like.
Instead, what I'd like to do
is describe some social facts
that, if we had technology
support for them,
could lead to more
productive behavior.
Your assignment is going to
be to invent the technology
to support the social facts.
Let me offer you three examples.
Could I have the next one?
The first collection
of social facts
has to do with the absent
meeting participant.
People have multiple
ongoing responsibilities.
Their responsibilities
obligate them
to participate in particular
real-time meetings.
Conflicting obligations
mean that not everyone
who should attend a given
meeting will be able to do so.
In fact, I'll bet that
every one of you who
is sitting in this
room today is missing
one or more meetings
back in your home spot
that you should be attending.
I think we need technology
support for the partially
present meeting participant.
Now, I have to tell you, I've
been in a number of meetings
where the people in the
room were partially present,
but that's not what I mean.
What I mean is
for the person who
should be at the real-time
meeting but can't be.
There should be
easy ways to review
the meeting after the fact.
And I think, actually, in Raja's
videotape of earlier today,
I caught a glimpse of how
that might be able to happen.
But that's only
half of the story.
That's good for the person
who can't be at the meeting.
But for the people
who are present
at the real-time
meeting, it should
be just as easy
for them to signal
the attention of an absent
member as a present one,
to ask questions of the absent
member at particular points,
to request action.
The only difference will be
that the partially present
participants will be
delayed for a bit.
So I hope you can invent
technology support
for the partially present
meeting participant.
Second social fact-- the meeting
isn't over when it's over.
Most meetings are embedded
in an ongoing social context.
A meeting doesn't
end when it's over.
People figure out, after
they walk out the door,
what they wish they had said.
They think of new
ideas to contribute.
They do what they said they
would do during the meeting,
or they don't and they
have to be reminded.
And so I want you to
invent technology support
for the post-meeting meeting.
After the face-to-face
meeting is over,
it should be easy
for participants
to slide new ideas, insights,
clarifications, contributions,
into the ambient information
environment of the meeting.
These could be from fully
present participants
or partially present
participants.
Third social fact-- group
membership is dynamic.
Groups add new members.
These members not only come
with a different set of skills,
which presumably is why
you put groups together
in the first place,
but they also
arrive with different
obligations, different ways
of doing business.
Bringing a new
member up to speed
is necessary for the member
to function productively
in the group and for the group
to function productively.
Creating a new group is simply
a special case of adding members
to an initially empty group.
I know that Marjory
Blumenthal had
been invited to
attend this meeting
and was unable to be present.
Marjorie runs the
panels that are
associated with
one of the National
Academy of Sciences committees.
And I think Marjory
will particularly
appreciate your
invention of technology
to support the dynamic
group member, technology
to support adding members
to an initially empty group.
The process of convening
these advisory committees
is one that she certainly
handles with expertise.
But it takes a lot
of time and energy.
The rest of us who
have to convene groups
of people from time
to time I think
could certainly appreciate that.
So what would technology support
for the dynamic group member
look like?
Well, one of the things that
we certainly would want to have
is a "who are these
people" button.
When a new person
enters a group,
he or she can easily learn about
the accomplishments, skills,
social circles of other
members, and vice versa.
Of course, it will
be easy to go deeper
if you wish by reading papers
or examining other work
products that are referenced
in the first level of the "who
are these people" display.
So that's one piece of it.
Second piece is
automatic configuration
of group communication
protocols.
Now, Nick was telling
us this morning
that, in some number of years,
we'll be able to shake hands
and all of that stuff
will pass automatically.
That's one way of doing it.
I guess I don't know
that I always want
to shake hands with everybody.
But it would be nice
to have other way--
well, it would be nice
to have other ways, maybe
that computers, without having
to get your hands involved,
could exchange
information about email
addresses, video conferencing
connections, the conventions
for producing work products that
each individual person brings
with him or her into
the particular group.
What versions of what
software do people use?
I don't know.
Maybe in the future,
there won't be versions.
But I sort of think
there will be.
And all of that
information should
get exchanged automatically.
That's automatic configuration.
Then there should be easy ways
to configure at least some
of the relationship protocols.
What do I mean by that?
How open or closed is the group?
When and in what form
can its work products
be sent outside the group?
Are drafts confidential?
Can drafts be
circulated to colleagues
outside the membership
or the particular group?
Who must review work
products before they
can be shared more broadly?
Who's in charge?
What's the calendar?
Now, these are [? gizzies. ?] I
think that's a technical term.
And I hope it's clear that
I'm not asking you just
to build [? gizzies. ?] Can I
have the next slide, please?
These are just
examples of what we
could hope to find in a
technology that supports
a scientist who is not simply a
solo information processor, not
simply a generic
communicator to the galaxy,
but a person who works through
simultaneous relationships,
structured relationships,
with other people
and other organizations.
I also hope it's clear
that my vision will require
new social inventions, too.
For example, the partially
present meeting participant
is a social role.
We'll have to develop norms and
beliefs about this role, ways
of proceeding.
The "who are these
people" button requires--
I can imagine this being
used with [? Avida ?]
for academic people.
But for non-academic
people, people
who do not work in an
academic organization,
we need useful
ways of summarizing
a person's accomplishments,
skills, social circle,
and so on.
Although I have
explicitly tried to focus
on science and the doing of
productive scientific work,
I'd like to look beyond
that domain for a moment
and suggest that technology
that can support scientists, who
already are working in multiple
simultaneous relationships,
may also support people
who need but do not
have a multiplicity of
ongoing relationships.
Many human beings
are physically alone
or feel socially isolated.
They perhaps could benefit
from having more people
in their ambient
information environment.
Some usenet groups, as I suspect
all of you in this room know,
already serve this function
to some extent for some people
today.
There is a newsgroup or listserv
for practically every malady
or misfortune of
the human condition.
And some of these have
been extraordinarily
important in the lives of
people who participate in them.
Now, technology to support
the dynamic group member
could be used to help manage
electronic support groups.
Support for the
post-meeting meeting
could be useful perhaps after a
parent-teacher conference, when
the parents think of
additional questions
they should have asked during
their 15 minutes allocated
with the teacher.
Support for the partially
present meeting participant
could be useful for someone who
is unable to attend a spouse's
medical appointment,
but who needs to be
involved in the treatment plan.
I think that the vision of
the solo individual made
more powerful, more
creative, more productive
through technology
will continue to be
beguiling, seductive, important,
fundamentally important.
New inventions for personal
computing based on that vision
will and should continue.
Could I have the
next slide, please?
What I've been
trying to do, though,
is ask you to think about
how the person embedded
in multiple social contexts can
be made more creative and more
productive.
Perhaps the real
challenge for the web
is to support social context
through socially structured
information.
I think that the challenge for
technologists, more generally,
is to invent support for
people who are not just
solo information processors,
not just generic communicators,
but who are embedded
in and accomplish work
through interdependence
with other people.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
That was sort of
different, wasn't it?
MODERATOR: Thank you very much.
SPROULL: You're welcome.
ENGELBART: Folks, question time.
Let's see, can we have
the house lights a bit
so that Lee can see you?
SPROULL: Hello, Michael.
Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: Michael Lesk.
Garrison Keillor
writes about the rise
of the shy, this feeling that,
as computer technology means
that interaction at a distance
replaces or supplements
face-to-face interaction, the
personality type that I guess
we associate with
automobile salesmen
will become less
important in society,
and the type associated with
the wimp sitting at a typewriter
will become more
important and dominant.
Do you think this is
accurate or that anything
like it will happen?
SPROULL: Actually, I've done
some research documenting
the rise of the shy.
And since I am one
of those folks,
I'm delighted to report that
computer communication does,
in fact, bring with it
benefits for folks like me.
I guess, though, I
think we'll always
still have automobile salesmen.
So I don't see it as one becomes
more influential or present
and one less.
I don't see it as a 0
sum game, necessarily.
Nor do I think that
real human beings
are going to stop talking to
real human beings face-to-face.
Stu.
AUDIENCE: Stuart Card.
As communication becomes easier
with larger and larger numbers
of people around the
world, and, in fact,
as we succeed in
being able to collect
more and more information
from the net and so on,
there is more stuff to do.
But the amount of time
somebody has remains constant.
So one of the real
issues seems to me
is the management of attention
among all of these things.
So can you conceive
of ways to support
the scientists to get
less communication
or to have more time,
to be more solo.
[LAUGHS]
SPROULL: No.
[LAUGHTER]
No, Stu, I didn't
make my point clear.
The scientist doesn't
do science solo.
The scientist does science in
a socially structured group.
And the group may be
able to figure out
ways to sustain its boundaries
so that information,
or stuff, data, isn't
totally swamping them.
I think that
graduate students are
wonderful information
filter retrieval
devices for professors.
And I don't want to propose
that we get rid of them
or replace their functions
with computing technology.
I really was trying
to make the point
that, if you try to
invent technology
for the solo
information processor
or the generic
society, you miss out
on a lot of the helpful stuff
that social organizations are
already doing for us,
structuring people's attention
already and providing
mechanisms and roles for helping
manage information flow.
AUDIENCE: Samuel Epstein
with Sense Media.
We operate something
called the sprawl.
Over a little a
year and a half ago,
we took some
technology developed
at Xerox PARC called LambdaMOO.
And we modified it enhanced it--
that's what we call it, some
people think we defiled it--
to support hypermedia, by
adding support for hypertext
and being able to inline
graphics and things like that.
And right now as a result
over a year and a half, we
now over 4,000 people
on our server in Hawaii.
And we call it a collaborative
hyper media server.
And it integrates together
text and graphics and chat
and mail and news posts.
And what I'm
wondering is if you've
done any research into some of
the social interactions that
are going on there.
It's a very rich
and diverse society
with a bunch of
people really working
together all over
the world to create
hypermedia presentations.
And this technology
is now spreading out
into lots of servers all over.
There's some stuff being done
at Brown University, as well.
And I was wondering
if you studied
any of these new
societies are starting up.
They're mostly populated with
people under the age of 20,
but they're doing
some incredible work.
SPROULL: Let's see.
The short answer to
your question is no.
I haven't yet studied
these communities.
I'm certainly looking
forward to doing so.
I mentioned, when I was
talking about the inventions
that I hope you folks will do,
the fact that there have to be
new social inventions as well.
And at the moment,
I'm not sure that we
have good social
inventions for how
to have 4,000
people work together
productively on anything.
People that you're describing
are doing that invention now.
At the same time, you're
inventing or modifying
or whatever the
technology tools.
So I look forward to having the
chance to try to systematically
understand some of these kinds
of things that are going on.
However, let me return for a
moment to productive science.
Whereas there may have been
400 authors on the top quark
papers, there certainly
were 4,000 people
involved in some way the
production of the research that
led to those papers.
And those organizations are
highly socially structured.
And I think it would be
interesting to learn from how--
to take the best of how
those organizations work--
and lord knows they do
not work perfectly--
but to take the best
of that and to try
to understand how
that can also be
useful in your
kind of new world.
Ron.
AUDIENCE: Ron Becker,
University of Toronto.
Lee, I'd like to thank you for
a very interesting presentation.
And it strikes me, though, that
the scientific communities,
in general, are resistant to
understanding and appreciating
and believing in the
social context of science.
And I go back to Bush.
It strikes me that he probably
should have seen some of that,
in terms of the
Manhattan Project, which
was sort of one of the first
examples of big science.
And I wonder whether,
first of all,
you agree that communities
are resistant to believing
this and appreciating
this and why this is.
Is it something about the way we
educate scientists or whatever?
SPROULL: Thank you
for the thank you.
I think it's partly a function
of how we educate scientists.
of how scientists are.
It's important that
there be a hubris,
that there be a belief that
the solo inventor, thinker can
change the world.
Usually, it doesn't
work out, but you
have to have that belief.
It's fundamentally
important to the survival
of the scientific enterprise.
So I'm not discouraged or
unhappy when I see that.
It's natural.
I think that often, as
scientists filled with hubris,
age, they come a bit more
to appreciate the importance
and necessity of
the social structure
and the social enterprise
that supports their work.
Unfortunately, that
sometimes happens too late
for them to then proselytize for
the funding of social science
research.
[LAUGHTER]
Peter.
AUDIENCE: Peter Denning.
There is a book that I always
like to take inspiration from
to combat the solo scientist.
And that's the book by Bruno
Latour, Science in Action.
Many of the other scientists
I've given that to to read
loved the book.
But when they get back to
their own academic departments
and start considering
merit and promotion,
they always look for
the solo contribution.
And they have all sorts
of ways to dig and see
if they can find it.
So we really do have kind of
a contradiction between where
your heart wants to go-- your
heart wants to appreciate
the social context.
But when you put
it in action, you
want to find the solo
inventor contribution.
Do you have any suggestions
on how to change that?
SPROULL: No.
And I don't think,
actually, that we need
to worry about changing that.
I think what you need to do
is continue to push, to invent
the technologies, to invent the
technology environments that
will make it obvious
to one and all
that scientific
collective work is
where the productive
work of science occurs.
But again, I don't want
to stamp out hubris.
I mean, it's kind of
obnoxious in faculty meetings.
[LAUGHTER] But
it's very important
for the scientific
enterprise to continue.
AUDIENCE: Another
question for you--
you named a few names that are
more on the solo inventor side.
What are some of the names that
you would hold up as examples
to look at for some
of the other parts
that you were
talking about there--
for example, workflow or CSCW?
SPROULL: Well, Doug
Engelbart, Doug Englebart,
and Doug Engelbart, to begin.
[LAUGHTER]
And I hope you heard that I
did acknowledge him initially.
All the work that
all of the people
in computer communications and
shared files are doing today--
I guess since I'm
not a technologist,
I never feel the need to
put down anybody's stuff.
I say, yeah, do more
of that, but let's
do some other things, too.
I want to expand your world,
not stamp out some things.
But let's add more
people and more ways
of thinking about inventing
technology support
for interdependent people.
MODERATOR: Thank you.
You getting hungry?
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, again.
SPROULL: Thank you.
MODERATOR: Terrific.
What's been really fun
about this symposium
for me is that I've been able
to introduce so many insanely
great people, in the words
of the late great Steve Jobs.
And certainly one of the
very topmost of those people
is Alan Kay.
Most of you identify him
with personal computers
and personal computing, and at
a time when that idea was still
embryonic or, as some of
us thought, lunatic fringe.
He's made seminal contributions
to object-oriented programming,
graphical user interfaces,
and window managers
via the Smalltalk language and
its programming environment.
He's always been interested in
the appropriate use of computer
technology, and
especially in the area
that appeals most
to me, education.
Alan is also, as
most of you probably
know, a very serious musician.
He was a professional musician.
And I try to characterize him--
I first thought of
him as a polymath.
But many people don't
know what that is.
So then I thought about
interdisciplinarian.
And Alan didn't like that.
So we came up together
with calling him--
Alan, what was the word?
Trans--
[LAUGHTER]
Then we had to fish for that.
AUDIENCE: [? Transcendalist. ?]
MODERATOR: So trans
everything that I know about,
here is Alan to
finish up for us.
KAY: Thanks.
Thank you.
We had to use the trans prefix
somehow since Ted is here.
Well, when I was
thinking about what
to do for this talk, when
I kept on thinking back
to the period when
I think that Bush
was most influential
in the ARPA world,
and I was thinking that it might
make a nice talk to just think
about the '60s, just to cut
it off at the end of 1969.
It just happened that 1970 is
when Xerox PARC started up.
So cut it off before Xerox PARC.
And when I was
thinking back, the more
I thought back,
the more I thought
of some of the
interesting people who
influenced that very, very
interesting and exciting
decade.
So I thought to start off with
a little trip down memory lane.
And as a kind of a
context for the talk,
I thought I'd start off by
showing you Arthur Koestler's--
Arthur Koestler was
a great novelist
who, in the last
years of his life,
became a psychologist
doing research
in creativity at Stanford.
And one of his
characterizations of creativity
sort of goes as follows.
He said that, our
minds are kind of
constrained to think within
contexts or within systems
of belief.
Sometimes they're
called paradigms.
But he was thinking of
something perhaps larger,
that we have a set of
commonsensical things
that we accept as reality.
And our thought patterns
sort of jog along,
staying in this particular,
here, a pink plane.
Every once in a while, we
have little outlaw thoughts
that are regarded as
lies by the pink plane.
And they're usually just
suppressed and pushed back.
And every once in a while,
when you're taking a shower
or out jogging or something,
you are relaxed enough to let
one of these outlaw thoughts
flourish a little bit.
And sometimes what
you find out is
that that little pink idea, when
expanded into the blue context,
is much more interesting than
it was in the pink context.
So the idea here is, terrific
ideas often hide behind
good ones.
Good ones are the
ones that are-- this
is like peer review and NSF.
[LAUGHTER]
They always fund good
research, but they almost
never fund great research.
Because six people
are trying to decide
whether what you're trying to
do is reasonable ahead of time.
And usually the way
it works is, you
decide whether it is reasonable
by looking what happened.
And then Koestler said--
and what happens
when you get one
of these big blue inspirations--
oh, sorry.
Well, I goofed.
I left out a slide, so
I'll just tell you here.
He said, there are
three reactions.
If you are telling a joke,
then the reaction is ha-ha.
If you're doing science,
then the reaction is a-ha.
And if you're doing art,
then the reaction is ah.
[LAUGHTER]
Because he points out that,
in each of these cases--
for instance, a
joke is something
that takes you down
the garden path
and then suddenly reveals
that the context you're in
is not the one you
thought you're in.
Science has this
aspect, as well.
You suddenly see it
was there all the time.
And often, besides saying
a-ha, you start laughing.
And of course, in art,
the whole idea in art
is to try and take
you out of the world
that you're in, your
commonplace world,
and reveal that there's
more to the world.
And one of the maxims
here is that, knowing more
than your own field is
really helpful in doing this.
And I've always thought that
one of the reasons the '60s was
so interesting is that nobody
was a computer scientist back
then.
And everybody who came
into it came into it
with lots of other
knowledge and interests.
Then they tried to figure
out what computers were.
And the only place they
had to use for analogies
were other areas.
And so we got some extremely
interesting ideas from that.
And of course, the
reason being educated
is important is simply because
you don't have any blue context
if you don't have any
other kinds of knowledge
to think with.
So engineering is one
of the hardest fields
to be creative in, just because
it's all about optimizing.
And you don't
optimize without being
very firmly anchored to
the context that you're in.
So what we're
talking about here is
something that is not about
optimization, but actually
in kind of rotating
the point of view.
Now, I was five
years old in 1945.
And I must have seen the
Life magazine article,
because I used to peel
through Life magazine.
But at that age, I was much
more interested in the manila
envelopes that life came in
because you could draw on them.
I'm sure that memex made no
impression on me back then.
I ran across it when reading
a science fiction story
by Robert Heinlein in the '50s.
And Heinlein had this
nice thing of taking terms
that he had found out about
and making them generic.
So he spoke rather casually
in the science fiction
story of a memex.
And whenever he did
that, I had found out
that that was a good
reason to go to the library
and trying to find out
what basis memex had.
That brought me to reading
Bush's article in the '50s.
And I'm ashamed
to say that, aside
from being interesting in
the science fiction way,
it made nowhere near
the impression on me
that it did on Doug Engelbart
and some other people.
It wasn't actually until
after I had met Doug Engelbart
and had heard him talk that I
realized that the ideas of Bush
had tremendous significance.
But I got that through
the eyes and the ideas
of Doug Engelbart.
So for me, I start off in
the very early '60s, 1961,
doing data processing
for the Air Force.
And back then, they didn't
really have operating systems.
They were very ad hoc.
And Air Training
Command had many bases.
And they had to
move files around.
And somebody, to
this day unknown--
I once tried to find out who it
was that thought up this idea--
had come up with
a wonderful notion
for allowing data to be
used from base to base
without having to have lots
of standards and formats
and operating systems.
And the way it
worked was this-- is
that each file on the Burroughs
220 tapes had three sections.
The first section
was a set of pointers
into the second section,
which was a set of code.
And the code knew about
the third section,
which was the formats
of the data records.
So in modern terms,
what you have here
is a generic interface, a
set of methods, and then
the data parts of objects.
So that is the
first example that I
know of in which this
object-oriented idea was
actually used.
Of course, it wasn't thought
of in those terms back then.
But it was something that was
used quite a bit in the Air
Force until they decided to
standardize on COBOL, in which
case all of this
stuff got thrown out,
and they went back
to processing data.
Another thing I saw
that didn't make
an enormous impression on me--
in fact, I should say, the
other thing that happened was
is that the third machine
I learned down here
in the Air Force was the
Burroughs B-5000, which
I think has seven of
the 10 best software
ideas directly in the hardware.
And at that time, I only
appreciated a couple of them.
The fact that it was
very easy to compile too
was pretty much all I
understood about that machine.
But it also had something
like this technique
of being able to deal with
[INAUDIBLE] indirectly.
They could do all of the
things that you're normally
used to doing with
bits but without having
to know what the bits look
like or where they were.
I didn't appreciate
that at the time.
In '65, I was actually
helping debug the Control Data
6600, which is my vote for
the first RISC machine.
It was about 1965.
It was a 10 MIP machine with
the kind of instruction set
and parallel operations that
we associate with RISC machines
today.
And while I was working on that
machine at Seymour Cray's lab,
I read this first
article by Gordon Moore
showing what had been happening
in integrated circuits
up to 1965.
Up to that point, it had
been doubling every year.
And so his first
cut at it, was what
if it kept on
doubling every year?
So that was interesting
to think about.
But from my standpoint, I really
couldn't make any extrapolation
or jump from this
freon-cooled 6600
that could detect how
many people were actually
in the room at a
given time, because
of the capacitance on its
doors from human beings
move moving around, to what
this might actually mean.
Now, a couple of years later,
Gordon Moore looked at it
a little more closely, looked
at the physics of the silicon,
and said, well,
it probably won't
be worse than a factor
of two every two years.
So that's that lower,
less sloped line.
And just for interest,
what actually
happened from about 1970 on
is that magenta line there.
So an interesting
thing about Moore's law
was, it was actually
a 30-year prediction.
And at least the one that
he did in 1967 or '68 or so,
he was able to
bracket successfully
what was going to
happen exponentially
in silicon for about 30 years.
Quite a remarkable, almost
unbelievable-- and I
think that most people
in the industry that
were going to be
affected incredibly by it
couldn't believe it at all.
At the most, they
thought it might
mean that they would have more
margins on their mainframes.
But the idea that this might
mean millions and millions
of computers, I don't
think affected anybody
at the time, including
Gordon Moore.
But when I went to
the University of Utah
sort of by an accident,
the first person I ran into
was Dave Evans, the
head of the department.
And the "this" that's
referred to there
was Ivan Sutherland's thesis.
He had a stack of
these brown theses
from Lincoln Labs on his desk.
And he had to take one of
these and go away and read it
before you got a desk.
And I must say, I didn't really
understand Sketchpad very well.
But it seemed to be about
a system that was not
just about making drawings.
And that was an
idea I hadn't really
thought about either back then.
But it was also the idea
that the drawings generally
had meaning, especially
in engineering.
And what you would really
like to do with these,
most of the drawings
you make in engineering
is to see whether
they actually work.
So the underlying notion
of Sketchpad-- in fact,
it was conditioned
by the fact that
the display on the TX-2
at Lincoln Lab-- which
was a machine, by the way,
about the size of this room,
maybe a little larger.
You're just seeing one
small part of it here.
The display was so bad
that it had discouraged
previous people
who had been asked
to do computer graphics on it.
And the difference
here was that Ivan
looked at this terrible
display and asked the question
we should all ask more often,
which is, what else can it do?
And when he thought
about it, he realized
that, although the pictures
were going to be terrible
and the drawings
done by the plotter
were not going to
be up to engineering
standards, that what else
it could do was to simulate.
And this is an idea that
was not strongly in any
of Bush's writings, in
spite of the fact that he
was one of the developers of
early analog computers, which
in fact did simulate.
And of course, he had funded
ENIAC, which simulated up
to a certain point.
But if you look in
his writings, you'll
see that he thought that
certain logical reasoning would
eventually be able to
be done by computing.
And he had some real jumps,
as far as transcribing speech.
But the notion of being
able to deal interactively
with simulations
was not something
that was really in his writing.
This was an idea that came
about from other people.
And I thought, just
for the fun of it,
to show you one
of the movies made
the late summer of '62,
the first set of movies
made of Sketchpad.
And in reviewing this,
there's one place
on the tape where
there's some tape damage.
So we'll just ignore
that as we go along.
Let's roll that first tape.
See you dip the light
pan into the ink.
And this rubber band
technique Ivan invented.
And why they call
it Sketchpad is
that you could put in something
very quickly and loosely,
and then give it some rules.
And here, the rules are to
be mutually perpendicular.
And what you saw
there is Sketchpad
figuring out how to do that.
Now, you'll notice this
is the first system ever
to have a window.
And in fact, the simulated
paper that he's drawing on
is about 1/3 of a mile
on a side, I believe.
And again, a couple of
lines drawn in quickly,
and then giving the constraints
to make them be perpendicular
to the lines that
they're terminated on.
And now the constraint
is colinearity.
So he's using these
two lines he drew
as guidelines for these dashes.
And now he will tell the
guidelines to be invisible.
So now he's drawn a
hole in this flange.
I think this is where
the damage shows up.
So now he wants to do a rivet.
It'll clear up in a second.
Sorry.
Or maybe it won't.
So he's using the
center of the crossbars
there as the center
of the circle.
And again, he's saying,
let's make these guys
mutually perpendicular.
Well, that changes the crossbars
and that changes the circle,
so you get a nice,
symmetric rivet.
In fact, Sketchpad could solve
some very interesting nonlinear
problems.
That bridge that you
saw on the slide,
you could draw bridges in,
give the rules for stresses
and strain of beams,
and it would calculate
how much stress and strain there
would be for given weights hung
from the bridge.
You could draw in electric
circuit elements, put
in Ohm's law, and so forth.
So now what he's going
to do is make some rivets
for his drawing here.
The controls here, he's using
one hand with the light pen.
And on the other hand, he has
some switches for commands
for different constraints.
And he also has some
knobs that he's turning.
So you can see this system
led to an interest in better
displays.
It's actually not even
a line drawing display.
It's putting up each
dot individually.
And in fact, there's
a kind of a twinkling
pattern that's put up there.
So he says, oh, I forgot there's
these crossbars on the rivets.
So I'll go to the master drawing
and I'll get rid of those guys.
And lo and behold, we see
that these rivets here
were actually instances.
So Sketchpad was
really the world's
first object-oriented system.
And he really had pretty
much all of the paraphernalia
of object-oriented programming.
And now he's made a
flange with a rivet in it.
And he can use anything
that he makes as a master.
So now he's making instances
of the flange with the rivet,
and positioning them and
scaling them and so forth.
So I once asked Ivan, how
could you possibly-- okay,
stop the tape.
That's enough.
So I once asked Ivan,
how could you possibly
have invented computer
graphics, the world's
first object-oriented software
system, and, as you can see,
one of the very
first dynamic problem
solvers that could do both
linear and nonlinear problems?
And Ivan said, well, I
didn't know it was hard.
[LAUGHTER]
And in fact, if you
read his thesis--
Bob, do you know, did it ever
get published out in the world?
No.
Besides still
being great today--
I mean, it's really
saying something
to be able to read something
that is interesting today.
That is, you can actually
learn something from it
by reading it today and
comparing what's going on.
What is really interesting
is the diffident
and even apologetic
tone in Sketchpad
because it didn't do more.
And this I think is true
of most of the people
that I think of as the
great people in the '60s,
is that they really
wanted it all.
So the image of what
Sketchpad should do
went far beyond what
it was able to do.
Although, when we look
at it today, we are just
awestruck by what he was willing
to take on just from scratch
and what he was
able to accomplish.
Well, right after
that, I found my desk.
And they had a tradition at
Utah that the latest graduate
student got the
latest dirty task.
And actually, I was graduate
student number seven.
So there were actually
quite a few dirty tasks
left for people to do.
And there was a pile
of listings and tapes
on the desk that were supposed
to be the ALGOL for the campus
computer.
It turned out to be the
first SIMULA system.
And the documentation was
quite incomprehensible.
And finally, another
graduate student and I
unrolled the listings
for it down the hall
of Merrill engineering building,
some 80 feet long or so.
And he crawled on it on
one part of the listing,
and I crawled-- imagine doing
this on a display today.
It was very useful that he
could crawl over it down there
and I was crawling over it down
here reading the machine code,
try and figure out
what the thing did.
And we finally realized that
it was allocating storage
exactly the way Sketchpad did.
In fact, it was kind of
a programming language
version of the same
kind of internal model
that Sketchpad had.
And the good news was,
Sketchpad couldn't solve
every problem you posed to it.
So it had a limited range
of things it could do.
But it did those very elegantly.
SIMULA was a generalized
programming language.
And so you could
pretty much do anything
that you could write
programs for, but none of it
was particularly elegant.
Now, in my checkered past was
a degree in molecular biology.
And this book had
come out in 1965.
This visit to Utah
started in '66 or so.
And I'd read this
book by Watson.
And one of the neat things
he did in this book--
this book is still in print,
but in a current edition.
The first edition
of this, I think,
was the first book
that ever tried to do
an assay of living things.
So the favorite animal
that molecular biologists
looked at then
was E. coli, which
is a bacterium we have in
our gut by the millions.
It helps us digest
certain kinds of food.
And by that time, they were
able to tell us that about 70%
of E. coli were water and
small charge molecules, which
actually were, of course,
important for the reactions
that were going on
there, but didn't
interact informationally.
But there were about 120
million organic components
that interact
informationally, mostly
enzymes, proteins of various
kinds, and DNA and so forth.
And if you work
out what these are
in terms of representing them
on a computer in a fairly
compact way, it's about 100
gigabytes of stuff going on.
And so I wrote down
there, it's about 50,000
2-megabyte desktops
worth in an E. coli.
And one of things
to think about here
is how fast the reactions
are actually going on.
At the temperature 37
degrees centigrade,
which is pretty much what your
body temperature is inside
of you, these medium-sized
protein molecules,
those little white things
that look like popcorn there,
are able to move
their own length
in about two nanoseconds.
People, when they take
chemistry in high school,
most chemistry teachers
actually don't understand
why chemistry works,
and they will shy away
from any questions from students
asking, just how can atoms
and molecules find each other in
order to have these reactions.
And the answer is, is
that the thermal agitation
at that level of scale
is unbelievably violent.
I'll give you an example.
If a carbon atom is about
the size of a tennis ball,
then one of these
protein molecules
is about the size
of a Volkswagen.
So in our scale, if you can
imagine a Volkswagen made out
of tennis balls, moving from
here, its own length in two
nanoseconds, and if you
multiply that out, you'll
see that that is a
scale speed that's
faster than the speed of light.
So if we were actually
transported down in size
to being able to look at what an
E. coli is doing at normal body
temperature, we would be
stunned by the violence.
In fact, we could not see
anything that's going on.
It's just unbelievably violent.
And that is why biology
and chemistry actually
works, something
that's very hard
to get into people's intuition.
So that is a very complex
and interesting structure.
And it happens to
be 1/500 the size
of a typical cell in our body.
And we happen to have between
10 trillion and 100 trillion
of these cells in our body.
And yet 50 cell divisions are
all it takes to grow a baby.
Now, think of taking something
much, much simpler, like a 747
that Lee Sproull was-- she
was talking about a 777.
And imagine what you have to do
to make it six inches longer.
The manuals for it are
bigger than the plane,
if they were listed out.
I'm sure they're on CD-ROMs now.
And yet a baby gets six
inches longer about 10 times
in its life, and you
never have to take it down
for maintenance.
So what we have
here is something
that is a kind of
informational machinery
that is just in a
different league
than computers are even
today, and certainly,
if you look at the number of
components in animal cells
and think of how many we have.
The other thing about
them is that they're
dying all the time.
And not only that,
they're actually
exchanging their structure.
So another interesting
thing that I
knew from molecular biology
is that, no atom in our body
stays in our body for
more than seven years.
And in fact, more than 90%
of the atoms in our body
are recycled every two weeks.
So if you think about this,
this is really quite startling,
if you think of yourself
as actually a pattern
moving through time and space,
sucking up energy and material
and reformulating
it to be yourself.
And yet every seven
years, you have not
a single atom, not
even in your bones,
that you had seven years before.
So this is a completely
different way
of thinking about things.
And things are going
wrong all the time.
But in structures like this,
more things are going right.
Well, something about SIMULA
got me thinking about computing.
I suddenly realized
that computers
were tiny, tiny, tiny,
little simple things.
Physically, they were big.
But compared to biology,
they were nothing.
Hardly anything was going on.
And the only reason
programming worked on them
was because people were
hardly doing anything.
And what came to my mind, it was
kind of like making a doghouse.
Which, unless you make
it out of toothpicks,
you can make a doghouse
out of almost anything,
because the structure is so
simple compared to the strength
of the materials.
It's only when you
go to big things
that you have to really
introduce architectures
to make them work.
And it suddenly
leapt into my mind
that all of the
programming that I
had known how to do in
the '60s was nothing, even
though it seemed hard to do.
But compared to what the
actual potential for building
structures was, we were
going to have to shift
to a different way of doing it.
So I had one of my
Arthur Koestler bingos.
And the bingo was that
the computers are not
like the clocks they seem to
be, where the clock, if anything
goes wrong, it stops.
The clock is something
you fix, and a clock
is something you build.
But in a biological
organism, you don't fix them.
You negotiate with them.
And you don't build them.
You grow them.
And so this notion
of, why shouldn't we
be building everything
on the computer out
of self-healing
intercommunicating parts
the way biology had?
And so this was very
compelling to me.
Because of course,
one of the reasons
why cells are a good idea is
that nature is very, very messy
about doing biochemistry and
requires enormous numbers--
for anybody who's
discovered it, you
might know that there
are hundreds of reactions
just to move electrons around.
And the reason is that the
energy margins are so small,
and that there was no grand
designer figuring out how
to move these electrons along.
Nature found out how, gradually.
But biochemistry is very kludgy.
And it requires
stable conditions.
So what the cell did
was allow this kludgery
to continue in a protected way.
Because nature
rarely undoes things.
It basically adds on
more kinds of things.
And this was a way of
taking messy things that
sort of worked and guaranteeing
that they would work better.
And then eventually,
of course, these cells
found out how to work together.
And now, looking back again
at SIMULA, what SIMULA was
was almost one of these things.
And they had been thinking
about simulating oil refineries.
And the thing that I
got out of it is, gee,
why not simulate
programmatic things?
Let's get rid of data
structures entirely.
We'll simulate those.
We can simulate
servers on a network.
In fact, these kinds
of systems are kind
of like servers on a network.
We can simulate
control structures.
physical objects.
We can simulate biology.
In fact, simulation,
again, thinking
about what Sketchpad
was about, is
one of the dominant
metaphors that is
in the destiny of the computer.
And there's one thing you
can do with a computer
that biology doesn't do well.
And that is, you
can share the DNA.
Biology does it by
copying the DNA.
And so when you want
to replace something,
it is really a
complex operation.
People are discovering how to
do that now for cystic fibrosis.
In the computer, you can
actually share the DNA
by extracting it and having
all the cells look to a master
copy.
So this is very powerful,
because it gives you
meta control over what the
system actually is all about.
So that was my first revelation.
It came in the end of '66.
And a little bit
later, Dave Evans
got me a consulting
job with a guy
by the name of Ed
Cheadle, who wanted
to build a little
computer for engineers.
And eventually, we wound
up building a version
of it called the FLEX Machine.
This is a picture of
it on its own display.
And we knew that it wasn't
the first personal computer,
because Wes Clark and
Charlie Molnar had already
done one called the LINC at
Lincoln Labs in the early '60s.
And we hadn't thought
about this machine
until Ed Cheadle
wanted to do one.
And then we realized that
somebody had already done it.
And we were able to learn quite
a bit of what you might try
and do on such a small machine.
This machine, by the way,
was made in some quantity.
And a lot of
fundamental inventions
were done on it, like the
things that look like deck tapes
there.
But deck tapes were actually
invented for this machine
by Wes Clark.
And here's a shadowy figure.
Now, this actually isn't
a picture of Bob Barton.
Because, as far as
I know, his pictures
have never shown
up on photographs.
He was called the Ghost Who
Walks because he was seen
outside of Merrill
engineering building,
and he was seen inside of
Merrill engineering building,
but he was never seen
entering or leaving.
Suddenly he would be there.
And then just as suddenly,
he would not be there.
He was the guy who designed
the Burroughs B5000,
and I think was the
greatest computer
designer who has ever lived.
And his influence in
his own inimitable way
had a lot to do with how this
little machine of Cheadle's
and mine executed.
We made it execute directly
one of the earliest
object-oriented languages.
And you see one of his
famous sayings up there.
Systems programmers are
high priests of a low cult.
So his idea was, if you have
to have an operating system,
then you might be
designing wrong.
And we realized that if you
had an object-oriented system
that you really didn't
have to have an operating
system, because it
actually would supply all
of the things you normally
associated with an operating
system, all by itself.
And so as I said, Sketchpad
had the first windows.
The first multiple
windows system I know of
was Sketchpad 3 that was
done by Timothy Johnson.
It showed you different views
of a three-dimensional object.
And so we needed to
have a windowing system.
This was done at the same time
as Ivan Sutherland and Bob
Sproull at Harvard.
We came up with a
clipping divider idea
that was rather
similar to, I think,
Danny Cohen's algorithm,
multiple views and so forth.
Now, right as we were
working on this stuff,
we were visited
by Doug Engelbart.
And Doug, I'm sure you remember,
but when you traveled around
back then, you used
to travel with--
you didn't travel light.
[LAUGHTER]
This was before video and stuff.
So he traveled with a
16-millimeter projector
and a film.
And the reason he traveled
with his own projector,
he'd had it modified so
he could do stop frame.
And the reason he did that
is that people were not
used to looking at cursors.
A lot of what he
wanted people to see
was what people did with
the cursors on the screen.
As I recall, the movie on
that one was a green display.
Because I think what
you showed back then
was the 3100, the control data
single user version of NLS.
My memory has it being in
color, and it was green.
So I think it was that
system that was shown.
So this was the visit that
actually changed our lives.
It certainly changed my life.
Because what Engelbart
brought was not just
a vision of interacting
with the system,
but he had a philosophical
underpinning.
And that philosophical
underpinning
is as important today,
maybe more important today,
even than it was then.
One of the phrases that he
used that I particularly
liked-- and I'm not sure
I still understand it.
But on the other hand, when
you're listening to this stuff,
total understanding
is not necessary.
But his phrase was, thought
vectors and concept space.
And what he meant, I think,
was that what you're doing
is creating an extension
of the kinds of spaces
that you think in terms
of inside of your head.
So it was actually, you were
creating an augmentation
of the ways of thinking and
the ways of representing
and the ways of
associating that was now
going to be extended, in a way,
somewhat analogous to the way
writing is extended,
but something more
like the way we actually think.
And that what we're
really interested in
is, in particular,
the collisions
of different kinds of ideas.
So if you think of
Koestler's diagram there,
you can see that
one of the things
that you would like to
do for maximum creativity
and getting out of your
rut is to constantly
have the system help you see
different sides to things,
to remind you that
you're in a context
and that there are
other contexts.
But anyway, his talk
was so fantastic
that, like all
really good talks,
I think everybody came away from
that realizing that this was
an actual turning point in the
history of design for computer
science.
And I think all of us were
very interested in trying
to do something with that.
I'm not going to show
you the movie because you
saw yesterday, of the 1968
demonstration in San Francisco.
Those of us who were there--
I was sick as a dog,
but I went anyway.
I had strep throat
and maybe pneumonia,
but I wasn't going to
miss it for the world.
And it still sticks in my mind.
It was one of the greatest
expositions of a new set
of ideas that I've ever seen.
I think everybody who
was there remembers.
And there were a
lot of people there.
There must have been somewhere
between 2,000 and 3,000 people
witnessing that.
Actually, I remember, that
was where I met Andy van Dam.
And for those of you
who have only known
Andy in the last
20 years or so, I
want to reveal to you that,
in 1968, Andy was a hippie.
[LAUGHTER]
He had long hair, and at
the very least a goatee,
if not more.
And he was a wonderful, angry
young man at that point.
And I remember him being
both tremendously impressed
with the Engelbart system
and amazed that it actually
did what it did.
That was my impression
of Andy back then.
And right around this time,
I visited Ivan Sutherland
at Harvard and met Bob Sproull.
Bob Sproull then
was an undergraduate
who was simultaneously
graduating from Harvard,
I believe, editor
of the yearbook.
But he spent almost
24 hours a day
helping to wire up
the clipping divider
for this first head-mounted
display machine.
And I understand that he
slowed down quite a bit.
He only works 20 hours a day
now instead of 23 and 1/2.
Now just one little plug here
for why all this stuff worked.
I think these are the most
enlightened funders that we
know of in this half century.
And I haven't heard Licklider's
name mentioned too much today,
although Lee mentioned it.
A lot of this was because of
his understanding, personality,
and vision.
And the succession of the ARPA
funders during this golden age,
before it became DARPA, were
Licklider, Ivan Sutherland,
when he was only 26,
Taylor, who later went on
to be the founder of the
computer stuff at Xerox PARC,
and Larry Roberts.
And their basic idea is to fund
people instead of projects,
one of the great
ideas of all time,
and fund directions
instead of goals.
I don't think anybody
else would have
funded Engelbart in those days.
Because I believe he must have
appeared, to most people--
in fact, I know he
appeared to most people--
as somebody who was completely
deranged and out of his mind.
And it's a real pity that the
ARPA funding from the '60s
didn't carry over
into the '70s, or I
think history would have
been quite different today.
Because sometimes the people
who can see the farthest
and see the deepest
are the ones that
are most difficult for the
bean counters to understand.
So I met Marvin back then.
So a typical Marvin
comment, I'd like to say you
don't understand anything if
you only understand it one way.
And he gave a talk on
education and mentioned
some of the stuff he'd been
doing with Seymour Papert.
And the talk was so
interesting, I read his book.
My other major was
in mathematics.
So I found in this book, besides
a lot of finite automata stuff,
some really interesting
ways of thinking
about universal computing.
Not just Turing machines, but
Marvin did a very funny thing
of, when he was
explaining Godel numbers
and how Godel made a kind of a
list structure out of exponents
of factorizations of integers.
Marvin built an entire LISP
system in one of the chapters
in this book using that
as the representation.
It was a really weird
way of learning LISP,
but it got me interested in this
way of thinking about things.
And let's show the
next little film.
Then I went to Rand Corporation.
This is still in '68.
And I saw this system.
Yep, go ahead and run it.
It's got sound.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- First, we erase a flow arrow,
then move the connector out
of the way so that we may
draw a box in its place.
KAY: Sees he wants a box.
It makes ones for him.
Now it's recognizing
his printing.
- The printing in
the box is being
used as commentary
only in this case.
The box is slightly too large
so we may change its size.
KAY: That's where modern day
window control came from,
literally.
- Then draw a flow from
the connector to the box.
Attach a decision
element to the box,
and draw a flow from it to scan.
We then erase the
flow arrows attached
to the process Post New
Area, and move the box
to a new position.
This allows us to
draw a new box.
[END PLAYBACK]
KAY: Okay, now you may have
seen character recognition done
worse on some products
today, partly because it's--
as Roger was saying, is that
they weren't trying to do the--
this was an 80-20
thing, where it
did what it did essentially
perfectly, almost perfectly.
You had to learn a little bit.
It did what it did, and
there were a bunch of things
that it wouldn't do.
But the result of it was that
the character recognition part
on this particular interface--
which the system was called
the GRAALL system--
the character recognition
was almost foolproof
and very, very transparent
in the user interface.
And there were some
further advances
done at Harvard and
elsewhere on doing this.
And this really
struck me as a very,
I thought of as a kind
of an intimate way
of interacting with a computer.
And then just a
little bit after that,
a couple of weeks
after that, I visited
Seymour Papert for the first
time out here in Lexington
and saw his work with children.
And that was another one--
see, for me, the
'60s was pretty much
a continual series
of holy shits,
just one after the other.
I think part of it is the
golden nostalgia, I'm sure,
from old farts.
But also I think actually this
stuff is still pretty neat,
even today.
I think the GRAALL
system was neat.
I think Sketchpad was neat.
I think NLS was really neat.
It was really a joy
to learn NLS have
a sense of what it
could mean to be
a virtuoso in dealing with
your external representations.
So Papert had another profound
idea, and that was that,
whatever the computer was, it
wasn't really a tool or even
a vehicle, in the sense
of being an automobile,
as compared to IBM's railroads.
But Papert thought
of it as being
a medium for powerful ideas.
Now Nicholas was hedging on
the definition of a medium.
I like Neil
Postman's definition.
Neil Postman says
technology is a machinery.
Like the printing
press is a machine,
the computer is a machine.
And he says, media
are the purposes
to which we put that machinery.
So for him the media
on the printing press
are things like Bibles,
indulgences, money,
comic books, romance novels,
pornography, political essays,
scientific essays.
So it was a wide range of
media that is all printed,
all represented,
all brought forth,
by the same piece of technology.
So if you think of media
as purposeful aims,
you see the strongest things
that Ivan Sutherland and Doug
Engelbart and some
of these other people
did were actually
creating media.
I didn't realize
that until I saw
Seymour working with the kids.
And he realized that
there's only one way
of thinking about this, to me.
And that was, it was a kind
of medium being brought forth
from machinery, and it
was going to be very
much like the printing press.
So flying back to Utah,
I sketched this thing,
which I later made a cardboard
model of, which later
became called the Dynabook.
And it was hollow.
I filled it up with
lead pellets to see
how heavy you could make
it before people didn't
want to carry it anymore.
And the result was
about two pounds.
So we had this
notion that, if you
were going to have an
intimate medium, then
you'd have to do mundane
things, casual things on it.
So we asked the
question, what would it
be like to take a
grocery list and actually
put it on a computer
and actually
carry it into the grocery store
and be willing to carry it out
with two bags of groceries?
What kind of computer
would that have to be?
And one of things
that was happening
in the end of the
'60s was that ARPA
had been doing the ARPANET.
But Larry Roberts and some of
the other people who were--
Bob Kahn and other people--
who were driving the ARPANET
were also thinking of
packet radio back then.
So in '69, I remember
driving around,
I think it was a Ford van with
a model 33 teletype in the back
and all kinds of radio
equipment, communicating with--
I think it was actually
Engelbart's computer
at SRI by radio at 10 characters
a second on this model 33
teletype.
So there's a whole
sense that computing
was going to get to be mobile.
And I think many you may
know that Larry Roberts
last set of things that
he was interested in doing
were to have a handheld radio
terminal that would be portable
and would connect you through
packet radio to the ARPANET.
And the other thing is--
I actually tried to
get the picture here.
But Lee, I'm sorry, we
actually were thinking
of this thing being networked.
Because I think networking
was part of the ARPA dream.
And the first cartoon I
ever did of this machine,
I'll show you later.
It shows two kids
playing Spacewar!
with each other,
each on their own
Dynabook,
communicating by radio.
So just having these ideas
here led to something
kind of interesting.
And that is, it struck me that
having a time-sharing graphics
terminal, this desktop computer
that Cheadle and I had been
working on and this
cardboard model,
reminded me of something that
had already happened hundreds
of years before.
And that was the
development of printing.
So on the far left
is a manuscript book
chained to its little desk.
And if you've ever been
in a medieval library--
they have one
still in Florence--
they're like the
size of this room
or maybe twice the
size of this room.
But they only have
about 70 or 80 books.
One of the largest
libraries in Europe in 1400
was the Vatican Library.
It had 372 books.
The richest man in France, who
was the brother of the King,
was a bibliophile and
had books made for him.
He had 154 when he died in 1435.
So these books
cost the equivalent
of millions of dollars.
And they are so rare that only
institutions could afford them.
In 1454, at the
Nuremberg Book Fair,
Gutenberg showed 20 bibles.
And people marveled
at two things.
One is how alike the
bibles were to each other.
That was a really new--
you could look at one page
and it looked just like the
same page on another Bible.
They'd never seen that before.
And the other thing was that
the costs had come way down.
These Bibles only cost three
years of a clerk's wages, maybe
$60,000 today.
And so you could think of those
as being workstations, kind
of things that smaller
institutions and towns
and some individuals could own.
And you'll notice that the
Gutenberg Bible was illuminated
because they made
every effort to make
it look like the manuscript
books on the left.
And then 50 years later, to
me, is when printing actually
happened.
And we have books that,
instead of being this size,
are now this size.
These are printed by Aldus,
whose last name was not
PageMaker.
[LAUGHTER]
His name was Aldus Manutius.
But he was the person
that the Aldus Corporation
took their name from.
And he was a Venetian printer
who had been a scholar.
And he went out
and decided books
should be this size because
he went out and measured
saddlebags in Venice,
because the first offering
from his printing press in
1495 was called the Portable
Library.
And instead of
printing just one book,
one kind of book, the Bible,
Aldus, over the next 35 years,
printed 40,000 different titles.
He and his sons went around and
gathered up all of the writing
that the Greeks and the Romans
had done that they could find.
They printed each one of them.
And many of the fonts
that we have today
were invented by
Aldus in order to make
this stuff more readable.
Aldus is also the inventor
of something quite unusual,
and that is page numbers.
Page numbers went in
to books the first time
ever 65 years
after the invention
of the printing press.
So they went in in
1516, and we know why.
They did not go in
there for sequencing.
Because the way
sequencing was done
was to print the word on the
next page down in the last line
so you could see how
the pages went together.
It did not go in there in
order to refer to other books,
because there were no really
standard editions of books.
Each press run was
2,000 to 5,000 copies.
Page numbers went
in there partly
at the instigation of Erasmus.
And they went in there
because they were just
starting to write
down arguments that
were so complicated
that they wanted
to refer people back to what
they had said previously.
So the first page
numbering systems
were done in order to, if you
will, hyperlink a piece of text
within itself.
So as you were following along
an argument sequentially,
the author could say, and
as I said back on page 162,
blah, blah.
And you could go back
there and check it out.
So page numbers
came in as people
started realizing that the
reproducibility of the books
allowed for much more
complicated arguments
to put in there
and not be garbled
by somebody who was trying
to copy the book by hand.
And this led, in
turn, to this idea
of trying to link the
arguments closer together.
That was a very
interesting sidelight.
And given that it took
65 years to happen
from the invention of
the printing press,
I also use it as a kind
of a metaphor for what
we haven't thought of yet.
Because clearly,
we are somewhere
between the desktop computer and
this Dynabook kind of machine.
And it's sobering to
realize that nothing
in the history of printing
counted in those 50 years.
There was a complete
transitional stage
where almost everybody
was looking backwards.
And if we look at the way most
people use computers today,
it's really pathetic.
Because most people do
not do hyperlinking.
Most people do not use computers
the way Engelbart thought
they should be used.
And most people do not
use computers the way
Ivan Sutherland thought
they should be used.
What most people are doing
is imitating paper, either
in prose, or imitating paper
in terms of accounting.
And that echoes all the
way back to Sumerian times.
Because as far as
anybody can tell,
the invention of writing itself
came about first to account
for the king's wine jars.
And then a few hundred
years after that,
they realized they
could also write down
some of their poetry.
So what's been going on in
computing has been very,
very-- as McLuhan
once said, we're
driving faster and
faster into the future,
but steering only by looking
through the rear view mirror.
And I think that's
been going on.
We can think of a
corner being turned
into the actual modern era.
I just gave a talk
in Korea whose title
was, "The Computer Revolution
Hasn't Happened yet."
And I would say that
it hasn't happened yet
until people start using
the computer for dealing
with thought vectors and concept
space and dealing with the idea
that you can have active dynamic
models of the things you're
trying to represent.
So that led to a kind
of a sense that there
were three different religions.
And we didn't know very much
about what the right-hand hand
religion was going to be.
But we could see that
they were certainly
at a mainframe religion, of
which Tom Watson, Jr. was
the Pope, that there
was going to be
a desktop revolution and
religion, because Moore's law
said that was going to happen.
And then we had this
more mythical notion
of pervasively networked
systems with computers that
were kind of like clothing.
So one of the last characters
I'm going to mention here
is Butler Lampson, who
talked to even faster back
in the '60s than he does today.
And he once came to,
actually, a meeting
on the ARPANET standards
and gave a talk
on capability operating
systems, in which he had been
working on one at Berkeley.
And what had happened is, the
meeting went later and later
and later.
And finally, Butler said, well,
I have a plane I have to catch.
And they said, when
do you have to leave?
And he says, I have to
leave in about 15 minutes.
And they said, well, would you
like to wait until next time
to give your talk?
And he says, oh, no, I'll
give my talk right now.
And he got up and
gave an hour talk
in 15 minutes on capability
operating systems.
And it was one of the clearest
talks I have ever heard.
And part of the idea
here is something
that is part and parcel
of objects, which is--
but in this kind of
operating system,
you think of clients
and services.
The services tend to be
generic, like printing
and searching and updating
and viewing and delegating.
And the clients are
different kinds of objects.
Objects in this sense
are usually large things.
They're the size
of Unix processes.
But they have certain
things that they
can do that are as
generic as possible.
There are a variety of
these kinds of things.
And then each one of these
clients of the services
has a different
set of privileges.
And the way it's
usually implemented
is by adding a little bitmap
to a protected pointer that
says which of these
privileges you have access to.
So this is a very compelling
way of thinking about--
in my mind, what I was
thinking about was,
gee, everything
should be an object.
And so the question
is, how could you
implement this kind
of protection, which
seemed very, very
useful and necessary,
even for ordinary programming.
How could you do it
in a fine-grained way?
And that leads to this notion of
designing in terms of concepts,
that you think of
behavioral concepts
and transmit it into
object-oriented terms,
you think of having
different kinds
of things, different
classes of things,
different types of things.
But you're trying to
design everything in terms
of these generic concepts.
And what you wind
up with is something
that, if you can limit
the number of concepts
that you're dealing with,
then your design tasks
become much easier.
And finally, we had--
although, again, I was only
thinking about the middle panel
here as opposed to the
one on the far left.
We realized that the ARPANET
would actually need objects,
for sure, because
networking, particularly
pervasive networking,
means heterogeneity.
When you have heterogeneity,
you better not
require people to
have to parse things
in order to understand them.
You really want to be able
to execute them in order
to understand them so that they
have their own understanding
with them.
And we felt that
something like objects
should actually be
adapted for the ARPANET.
That was a little bit too early.
That was brought up in one
of the meetings back there.
It was felt to be a
little bit too early.
But I think we can see from
the state of the internet
today that this is absolutely
critical to get out of a data
structure-oriented way
of doing things, which
is kind of like
going back to MS-DOS
and trying to get to a situation
where the objects that we
interact with don't have to be
from the same object-oriented
language, don't have
to have been created
on the same kind of
machine, but nonetheless,
can interact and
interoperate with each other.
And then finally, towards
the end of the '60s,
I finally went through
this half page of code
in the LISP 1.5
Programmer's Manual
and realized that McCarthy
had actually come up
with an incredible way of
thinking about what programming
should be.
Now, he was doing it to prove
a different kind of point.
And as he says himself,
it wasn't his fault
that Steve Russell sat
down and made it work.
But once it did get going, it
provided a completely different
way of thinking about what it
means to implement programming
languages.
And I started thinking
very seriously
about what an OOP
language would be like
if it were set up like LISP.
I think of this as the Maxwell's
equations for computers.
Because everything you
can do with a computer
and in a high level form
is there on that half page.
So that's a very,
very interesting thing
to spend a Sunday
afternoon going through.
And I think everybody
who has gone through this
and understood it, spent
those couple of hours
to go through it, remembers that
time when they suddenly said,
oh, wait a minute.
Now, it wasn't
helped by the fact
that this particular rendition
in this book has a bug in it.
It has one bug.
And that bug can cause us
an extra couple of hours
to be taken until you're
quite sure that you understand
all of it and that
there really is a bug.
It turns out there is.
And what is the bug?
Well, of course, they left
out one set of parentheses.
[LAUGHTER]
Then the last part of
the '60s was realizing--
and this again, I
want to say something
about Doug Engelbart and NLS.
The other part of his project
that was so impressive to me
as a graduate student was, when
you visited the Augmentation
Research Center at
SRI, what you found
was kind of the epitome of
what a research project should
be like.
They had lofty goals,
lots of committed people.
They were willing
to do any amount
of building their own hardware
and software, which they did.
They built their
own display system.
And they built their
own IO devices.
And they built most
of their software.
And they helped modify the
operating system in order
to make all of this stuff work.
And actually, the other thing
I should have mentioned,
I think everybody
noticed yesterday
that NLS was kind of
zippy as far as response.
Wouldn't you like to have
your desktop computer
be as responsive
as that system was,
instead of lumbering around
trying to bring stuff up?
Well, I realized that, in order
to do a computer for kids,
that what we had to do was
to build a bunch of them.
And this is one of the
entries in my notebook
back then of what
I wanted to build.
And at that point,
Xerox PARC came along,
and we got a chance to try
some of these ideas out.
Now, to me, the moral of some
of this looking back in the past
is that it is incredible how
powerful a new context is.
And it's also incredible
how stultifying it
is after a couple of years.
I didn't realize until
looking back on this,
but I think all of us
have had this feeling
that the very things that
made our ideas work when we're
in a context were also the ones
that held us up from thinking
about other ideas.
So these contexts wear out.
But we can only think about
things in terms of context.
When we go to one
context to another,
we get life for a few years.
But then there's
a syndrome, which
I call the subgoals becoming
the goals, that sets in.
Usually the subgoals
are hard enough
to require a couple
of years work.
And once you've been working
on them for a couple of years,
they become the
goals of the project.
And all of a sudden, it's hard
to remember why you started
the project in the first place.
So I think one of
the hardest things
to do on these large
scale things that
require so many different
things to be done over
so many years is to
constantly be able to renew
what the actual dream was.
And it takes so long to
get people to understand
what these ideas are.
This is one of my
favorite slides,
because it shows hand axes
from to prehistoric periods.
The one on the left,
you might notice
that when you chop
with it, it chops you.
Because the place where
you grab it on the bottom
there is pretty sharp.
It's almost as sharp as the top.
And then a little
bit later, somebody
came up with a hand ax that
was blunt around the bottom
so it wouldn't chop you as much.
And according to
archaeologists, the period
of time between these two
was about 200,000 years.
So you can imagine, every
generation, probably somebody
sitting around a
campfire chopping
with one of these things
on the left, said, jeez,
this is hurting.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll just chip this away.
And probably got
burned at the stake
for going against the
traditions of the tribe, which
are probably something
puritanical like,
work is good for you, sure
it hurts, and so forth.
And then finally,
probably by an accident,
some chieftain of some tribe
came up with the blunter end
one and made it a
rule that everybody
should have blunt end ones.
And that's how this
change happened.
So there's this low
pass filter to reality.
And the biggest
example of it is what's
happened to personal
computing since 1980.
The low pass filter has been
so dominant that all we get
is about a 60 cycle hum for most
of these ideas from the '60s.
If we look at what
most people are
doing with personal
computers, they
have unbelievable resources.
Engelbart's SDS 940
had 192 K and it
ran 20 users as a time-sharing
system with 192 K.
We've got megabytes.
The system is much less
responsive than it is.
The user interface
is worse than it was.
And humankind has sat down for
one of these 20-year slumbers
right now, bedazzled by
stuff that isn't very good.
So the last slide is a
metaphor for this whole talk.
And that is something that
was actually found out
about frogs at MIT here.
And that is that
frogs don't know
what their food looks like.
So if you take their normal
food, which are flies,
paralyze them with
a little chloroform
and put the flies out
in front of the frog,
the frog will not eat them.
The frog will just
starve to death.
But if you flip a piece
of cardboard at the frog,
it will try and
eat it every time.
Because what it thinks food is
an oblong thing that is moving.
And I think this is a good
metaphor for us scientists.
Because the way I think of the
flies is that they're ideas.
The ideas are in front
of us all of the time,
and we just can't see them.
What we have to do
is periodically find
a way of realizing
that you can't see
unless you admit you're blind.
And every time we
admit we're blind,
we can actually see a bit.
And then we can push
on to the next stage
of this grand adventure.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Thanks a lot, Alan.
We'll take a few questions
directed to Alan specifically.
And then we're going to
arrange for the panel.
AUDIENCE: I just want
to go back to one
of your early slides
of the dog house,
that I think actually the
dog house is the better
model than the bridge.
Because if we look at
the scale, the bridge
is about a middle-sized
construction,
rather tiny compared to
cities and societies,
which are totally
unarchitectured,
yet somehow work.
The thing is, we don't quite
understand how they work.
I think that's
really a challenge
for intimate computing.
KAY: No, but you're
making my point.
The whole point about
biology is that it
works in the face
of error and not
having to be
strictly architected.
AUDIENCE: Okay, then
I misunderstood.
KAY: I said dog
houses work simply
because they're
so simple compared
to the strength of materials.
So that's a different
point than the--
but the very point I was
trying to make about,
when you go up into
real complexity,
you have to find a
way of getting things
to work together, even when
they don't want to terribly.
So the Constitution of the US
is a pretty interesting meta
program since--
AUDIENCE: And the nice
thing is it's small.
KAY: It's very, very small.
And it's not a set of laws.
It's a set of
principles for dealing
with millions of only semi
co-operative components, namely
us.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Not so much a
question, but a comment.
It seems to me that you
focused on the '60s.
And it's probably
natural to think
of the golden age
in the area where
you get your own awakening and
you start to become productive
in a creative part of society.
But for everybody
who's in the field,
their golden age
is probably going
to be some other
decade or whatever.
As I went back and
just sort of picked
another one, like the
'70s, and just sort of made
the list of things
that came out there.
This was the era when ARPA
had a D in front of it.
I was thinking of Minsky's
adage about not being
right about something
for too long.
I made the list of the things
that came out of that decade.
And it seems to me they
were pretty impressive.
The first work on
speech understanding
in a systematic way
started in that decade,
with Allen Newell's push.
The work on image understanding
started in that decade.
The internet came
out of that decade.
The microprocessor was in
the decade of the '70s.
The personal computer
really came out
of the decade of the '70s.
The work on LANs, radio
networks, and the DLSI design,
the thing that empowered
the universities,
came out of the '70s.
And probably an awful lot of
the object-oriented programming
work came out of
the '70s, as well,
although you would probably
know better than I.
So it seems to me it's a
little unfair to cite the '60s
as the golden age relative
to all other ages,
because I think it's
relative to our own contexts.
KAY: Well, I hope I
wasn't doing that.
Because of course, the most
productive period in my life
was in the '70s,
not in the '60s.
The reason I picked
the '60s was that was
when I think a
lot of these ideas
manifested itself in
such a way that we could
see that they were possible.
A lot of the shoes were
dropped in the '70s.
But I certainly think of the
'70s much more as engineering.
In fact, most of the
stuff we did at Xerox PARC
was kind of a second engineering
pass on things we'd failed at.
Because the things were
bubble-gummed together.
We didn't completely
understand them.
So for instance, one of the
dicta that Butler Lampson got
us to agree to in the
early days of Xerox PARC
is, we should never
do something that
isn't engineered for 100 users.
And that made us much
more conservative
than we had been in the '60s.
But it also added much
more reality to the things
that we did.
And of course, a lot of
the success that we had
was because we could
make 100 of something
or make a machine that you
could run 100 people on or make
software that you
could move around.
But to me, that was very
different than the--
I think of it as being less
creative and more engineering
than the '60s.
But as you say,
other people might--
it just depends
on when you start.
From my standpoint, it's
silly to try and compare
one person's gods with another.
But I think that, to me, Ivan
Sutherland and Doug Engelbart
did the most towering and
important stuff in the last 35
years.
And I think that stands
up pretty well today.
Yes, somebody else was--
okay, great.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Before we
go into the panel,
I want to do a couple of things.
First of all, Paul Penfield
has to leave for a memorial
service, and I'd
like to thank him
on our joint behalf for
a job very well done.
He and a lot of people at MIT,
like Ed over there and Scott
and lots and lots
of other people,
put in real quality
time making this happen.
So thank you very much,
Paul, and the rest of you.
[APPLAUSE]
The second thing
I have to tell you
is, Paul has an announcement.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PENFIELD: I just want to thank
everyone for coming to this.
This has been a real
wonderful opportunity for me
to see some aspects
of this community
that I hadn't been as
familiar with as I should.
And I want to personally thank
Andy for putting this together.
Andy says that we did
the [INAUDIBLE] job.
But I can assure you that
Andy, in setting this up
over the past several months,
has put it in far more effort
than anyone at MIT has.
And I think the whole group
deserves to thank Andy
for organizing this.
[APPLAUSE]
MODERATOR: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
As you know, it was
the three guys from EBT
who really thought of it,
and Lisa who executed it.
But I got to invite
the speakers.
That was the best part.
Speaking about speakers, you
all know what day it is today?
AUDIENCE: Friday.
MODERATOR: Friday the 13th.
Now, I'm not normally
a superstitious person.
However, I have to find some
explanation for what happened.
Here's what happened.
Inadvertently, Ted Nelson's
tape got recorded over.
So we do not have an official
record of his great speech
here.
I just found out about
this a little time ago.
This is not a joke.
I'm sorry.
I wish it were.
And we are trying to find
people who may have recorded it.
There are a couple
of possibilities.
There may be some folks out
over the MBone, who recorded it.
It's a classic point of failure.
And despite all
of the duplication
that we had in equipment and
people, something went wrong.
In any case, we asked Ted what
he would like to do about it.
He was a gentleman to the core
and took it exceedingly well.
And I think I would have gone
straight through the ceiling.
Fortunately, he's
jet-lagged and so
he didn't react quite as
strongly as he might have.
As I said, he handled
it beautifully.
The folks here at
MIT thought that
what might be fun
and interesting
is to let him have
the last word, as it
were, a reprise performance.
And any of you are
welcome to stay
while Ted tries to
lay down another track
for the historical record.
And we'll do that
after the panel.
Some of you have to go.
Some of you have
other things to do.
Some of you, whatever.
You're all more than
welcome to sit in
on this as Ted tries his
best to recapture the moment.
We apologize.
AUDIENCE: Forget that moment.
We'll do another moment.
MODERATOR: We'll do
another moment, of course.
So that's where we are.
We're going to take
a couple of minutes
to set up the chairs for the
panel, and then we carry on.
Well, why don't we
just get started.
And you can fire at will
at the people who are here.
Fire when ready.
AUDIENCE: All right, I'll go.
We started this
discussion by looking
at Bush's vision of memex.
And we just heard Alan
talk about the golden age
of the '60s.
And here we are
in 1994, and we've
ended up with Windows, which
is kind of a bleak thought.
So I'd ask any of you who
were interested to postulate
where we would be if
Windows never existed.
Would we have had to
invent it, or would we
be someplace different,
and where would we be?
PRESENTER 1: The question
is Microsoft Windows?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Microsoft.
MODERATOR: Wait a
minute, wait a minute.
Use the mic.
I'm sorry.
Clarification-- is the
question Microsoft Windows
or windows in general?
AUDIENCE: If Microsoft didn't
exist as a market force,
where would we be?
PRESENTER 1: We would
be missing nothing.
Microsoft doesn't even
claim that they're
a highly innovative company.
They take programs that have
already existed and sold
well from other vendors, such
as Lotus and WordPerfect,
and they do a
commercially better job
rewriting these programs
and selling them,
as Excel and WordPerfect.
So we wouldn't be missing
any important technology.
AUDIENCE: So you think we'd
be in exactly the same place?
Personal computing
would look the same.
PRESENTER 1: As
far as I can see.
ALAN KAY: At PARC--
because I didn't talk about
the PARC phase of the thing.
But at PARC, one
of the goals was
to do NLS as a
distributed system.
And all of the Altos there
had the five finger keyboards
as well as the mouse on them.
We basically loved NLS.
And we'd done a
few modifications
which we thought even sped up--
NLS, part of the interaction
scheme on it, I believe,
was because the analog mouse,
there was some drift in it.
So one of the
things that they did
was to say what kind of a
thing you were pointing at.
So you'd say, move character
or move word or move paragraph
and so forth.
It was kind of a procedural,
where you gave the command
first, and then you'd
go bug, bug, and then
Command [? accept. ?] And
we realized at Xerox PARC
that you wanted to have a
speedy scheme for interacting.
And we thought we
could go even one
better by selecting the object.
So you'd select
the thing that you
were going to do something to.
You would give the command.
And then in the case
of move character,
you'd go select, move, select.
And that would do it
with fewer keystrokes.
Now the abortion that
happened after PARC
was the misunderstanding
of the user
interface that we
did for children,
which was the overlapping
window interface, which
we made as naive as
absolutely we possibly could,
to the point of not having
any workflow ideas in it.
And that was taken
over uncritically
out into the outside world.
So we have many systems, like
Lotus Notes and many mail
systems, that,
when you say reply,
it comes up with a window
over the very thing you were
reading, as though there
weren't any connection
between these things.
So this is an abortion to me.
But it's basically part
of the whole field.
Whereas our notion was
that, you start the kids off
on this fairly
simple, naive thing,
and then there would be
an actual progression
where you would get up
to this several commands
a second kind of thing
that you could do with NLS.
If you've ever seen anybody use
NLS, it is really marvelous.
Because you're kind of flying
along through this stuff,
several commands a second.
And there's this
complete different sense
of what it means to interact
than you have today.
So I characterize what we
have today is a wonderful bike
with training wheels on.
And nobody knows the
training wheels are on,
so nobody's trying
to take them off.
So maybe Doug has
a comment on that.
So I just feel like
we're way, way behind
where we could have been,
if it weren't for the way
commercialization turned out.
ENGELBART: Well, strangely
enough, I feel the same.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah, that's part of the easy to
learn and natural to use thing
that became sort
of a god to follow,
and that the marketplace
is driving it.
And it was successful and you
could market on that basis.
But some of the diagrams
and pictures I didn't quite
get to the other day
was, how do you ever
migrate from a
tricycle to a bicycle?
Because a bicycle is very
unnatural and very hard
to learn, compared to getting
on a tricycle and riding.
And yet, in society, it has
superseded all the tricycles,
essentially, for anybody over
five years old or something.
So there's a lot.
And the whole idea of high
performance knowledge work
is yet to kind of come
up and be in the domain.
You got to make it easy.
It's still the orientation of
automating what you used to do,
instead of moving to a whole new
domain, which obviously you're
going to learn quite
a few new skills.
And so you make
analogies of saying,
suppose you wanted to
move up on the ski slopes
and be mobile on skis.
Well, just visiting them for
an afternoon is not going to--
you're not going to find--
I'd love to have photographs
of skateboards and skis
and wind surfing and
all of that to show you
what people can really do if
they have a new way supplied
by technology to be mobile
in a different environment.
And none of that can be done
if people insisted that it
was an easy to learn thing.
Anyway, so moving
your way around those
thought vectors
and concept space--
I'd forgotten about that.
AUDIENCE: You said that, right?
ENGELBART: I must have.
That's so good.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER 2: You did.
It seemed to come
naturally at that point.
ENGELBART: Anyway,
that's a nice formulation
of what I've been saying.
But it's to externalize
your thoughts in the concept
structures that are meaningful
outside, and moving around
flexibly and manipulating
them and viewing them.
It's a new way to operate on a
new kind of externalized media,
to explain it like that.
So to keep doing it in
the model of the old media
is just a hangup
that someplace we're
going to break that
perspective and shift.
And then the idea of high
performance and the idea
of high performance
teams, who've
learned to coordinate to
get that ball down the field
together in all
kinds of operations,
very different operations.
So I feel like the
real breakthrough
for us getting
someplace is going
to be when we say, all
right, let's put together
high performance
knowledge work teams.
And let's pick the
roles they're going
to play within our
organizations in some way
and such that, even though
they operate very differently
from their peers out in the
rest of the organization,
they can interact with them and
support them very effectively.
So there are roles like that
that would be very effective.
And everyone else
can sort of see,
because they're interacting,
these guys, what they can do.
And suppose it does take 200
hours of specialized training,
et cetera, like that.
That's less than boot
camp, something like that.
So anyway, to me, that's
kind of the only way
the evolution--
one of those boxes
in that paradigm
map about deployment
was really coming
down and showing you
that special purpose teams
is one kind of thing,
the way that they can propagate.
And very different from
moving a group of people
who have an existing set
of staff and processes
and methods and
skills and equipment,
and trying to move
them all together.
It's a practically
impossible task
to do that in any
significantly large step
without having
casualties in there that
just aren't all equipped
to be mobile in that space.
Anyway, so there's a lot
to go with that thing.
And it all stems
from looking at today
and saying, why
do we accept that?
That's the modern thing.
And it's almost like a religion.
In any other company, I'm
afraid to bring that out.
But maybe I have to
run from this one, too.
NELSON: I hadn't heard
you say this before.
So you're basically
proposing information--
MODERATOR: Wait, wait,
wait, use the mic.
NELSON: I hadn't heard
you say this before.
You're basically proposing
posing some kind of information
SWAT team that can move
swiftly through an organization
or it's going to be some elite
[INAUDIBLE] in the files.
This is a very exciting
and interesting concept.
But how would that
function organizationally.
AUDIENCE: We did
that to your tape.
[LAUGHTER]
NELSON: Obviously,
they got in there.
ENGELBART: No.
I mentioned the other
day that, if you're
going to have a strategy to go
ahead with your organizations,
you just can't lift
them all at once.
So the strategy I
finally worked out
is that, to that
improvement infrastructure
term I mentioned, I didn't
show you much below that.
But in that improvement
infrastructure,
there are roles in the
improvement process
for high performance
teams that would really
be helping the information
and the improvement process
go about.
And then they're roles
for them to be plugged
into an organization
and to function
that would be very supportive.
And this is all assuming
that those are the outposts
that everybody is going
to start moving there as
well as you can.
But you just can't lift
the whole organization
in some very radical way.
And so that's a
part of the process.
So yes, they are an elite team.
But you're assuming that,
in some number of years,
you'll learn how to get the
whole organization there.
PRESENTER 2: I think that
the gruesome practical point
is that finding a path
of [? thought ?] vector
through concept space to where
you are may be one thing.
But the transition path
to get the world there
may be very, very
different path.
So that you have to find a
path of whatever they are,
of pushing the world vectors,
where each step is downhill
for the person who
has to make that step.
So now, your original
question was,
has Microsoft's existence
and the dominance of DOS
and later Windows helped?
Basically, if at some point,
Microsoft has to make a change,
obviously that's going to be
one of the more difficult people
to put them in a position so
that the next step is downhill.
And it can happen.
And one of the things
that can make that easier
is if instead of having just one
operating system, you have two.
You might ask, for example,
what would have happened
if the Mac hadn't been there?
Maybe we'd still be using
DOS without Windows.
So there's an argument
which says, this is easier.
I wouldn't say it's
easier in a situation
where you don't
have any dominance,
you don't have any commonality.
Maybe that's what held up
Unix, the people who are all
developing things on the
Unix, in fact, because they
didn't have enough commonality.
It was difficult to make code
that you could pass around.
It was difficult to
spread things around.
So the fact that you've
got DOS there at least
means that, if you're not trying
to change the operating system,
you can roll out all kinds of
bits of software very quickly.
So that's got a great advantage.
The internet and
DOS, if you can do
what you want with
the internet and DOS,
then you can do it very
quickly and roll it out.
It's when you want to
change the internet
or you want to change
DOS that you've
got yourself a big problem.
The way I hope it will
maybe work for the web
protocols and all the
these web standards,
which we hope we'll
be able to evolve
from their kludgy current
state into the beautiful golden
dream, is that in any case
where you lay down a standard,
you also allow there
to be a second.
And you show a path whereby
if a third one comes up
which is better, you can
move in that direction.
So you always have one on
the heels of the first,
keeping it honest.
And you have a
transition, a hook in it,
to be able to unhook it
all together later on.
KAY: So American television is
kind of a counter example of,
in the effort to make it
really easy for everybody
to watch television.
I'm not sure I see any path back
upwards towards enlightenment,
because the advertisers
are quite happy.
And so is Microsoft.
It's quite happy with
the stage of blindness
that everybody is in right now.
So it's a great idea.
There's an economic law called
Gresham's law, which says,
the bad that's easily
produced drives out the good.
Because it resets the
whole notion of normality.
Personally, I think if
somebody invented a bicycle
and it didn't exist today, they
couldn't get anybody to buy it.
Because it takes more than
five minutes to learn.
That is really pathetic
when you think about it.
NELSON: As far as
television is concerned,
the operative phrase
a few minutes ago
was "a comfortable step down."
ENGELBART: I'd say you want to
make your steps up comfortable.
It's kind of take stress
but you have to minimize it.
And the older you get, the
harder it is to change.
And I keep getting that
thrown back at me, and says,
you're going to ask
all the old guys that
are ready to retire that they're
supposed to shift and change?
And the only answer
you can really get
is, A, look, there's a lot of
potential for organizations
to get a lot more confident
in their knowledge work,
just a lot more.
And it's going to
take a lot of change.
And the organizations
that learn how to do it
are going to be successful,
maybe the only ones that will
survive, including mankind.
So look, we've got to get there.
So what you need
to do is say, look,
we have to find
a strategy that's
as smart as possible
for accommodating all
of the human and
social characteristics
that change has to
cope with, as well
as the dynamics and the
expense of changing, et cetera.
So we have to find a strategy.
So that's the major push on our
bootstrapping thing, to say,
yes, it looks like a
very smart thing to do
is to build an appropriate
improvement infrastructure.
And then as rapidly as
possible, get the improvements
and these capabilities so they
can plug into the improvement
and structure, too.
So that you're improving
your improvement process,
maybe even faster
than the other.
But that just looked like the
only strategy I could think of.
And there's a practical
way to go after it.
So strange as it sounds,
that's what we're after.
MODERATOR: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Okay.
I wanted to thank Alan
for his retrospective.
Oh, I'm Mike Zyda, Naval
Postgraduate School.
I want to thank Alan for his
retrospective of the '60s.
And there was an
important slide in there
that I think got kind
of muddied, which talks
about the golden age of ARPA.
And I liked the print
on the bottom, which
is, fund people not projects.
Try and point out, actually,
I receive a lot of ARPA money
right now.
And ARPA today is very
different from 30 years ago.
I've been on my own money
for 22 years, so I know this.
I had an interesting
experience about in June, July
of this year.
I received a note from my
ARPA program manager saying,
we have a new director of ARPA.
You need to take your proposal
that I've already sent you
the money for and provide
a three and four word
title for each task, a
task number for each task,
a start date for each task,
an end date for each task.
Were you over budget on
budget or what for each task?
And the director of ARPA was
going to look at the tasks
and say which ones he was
going to fund for money
that was already there.
And so when I saw your, fund
people not projects, and then
I'm saying, fund
projects not tasks.
[LAUGHTER]
So I'm a little bit
nervous about the way
we're going right now.
So this is not an
attack on ARPA.
ARPA's been extremely
good to me over the years.
But just the orientation
of the bottom line
is a little bit out
of whack, I think.
So I'd like to
hear some comments.
ENGELBART: That really isn't
just in ARPA, in our industry,
too.
It's like, if you can't explain
it to me in five minutes,
I don't think I should
even consider it,
somebody will say to you.
And you say, well, you can't
explain something very novel
in five minutes.
And they want the bottom line.
And you say, I'm convinced
in the general thing.
There couldn't be anything else.
You have to get there.
But that isn't the kind
of thing that sells.
And so it's sort of some kind
of modern type way to manage.
But I think it's going to get
our country and our industry
into real trouble.
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
this presupposes I
know what the system
is going to look
like precisely at the end when
I'm handing in the proposal.
ENGELBART: Well, it's
the kind of thing
that can work when you're
making incremental improvements.
And so that the guy that's
evaluating knows the system
and knows that, yes, if
you get delivery that much
faster to the
customer, and that's
what your bottom line
is, yeah, I can see it.
Okay, good.
But it really doesn't
work if you say,
I got a brand new
material that'll
make your products
very different.
And I can't tell you
how much different,
but you've got to explore it.
You can't do that kind of sell.
PRESENTER 3: Yeah, if I could
respond to that briefly.
I guess I would start by
saying that one person's bug is
another person's feature, often.
And that there are different
models of how the system ought
to work, just as there are
different models of life,
depending on what stage of
evolution and involvement in it
you are.
ARPA [INAUDIBLE], I would say.
Not to try and defend
any specific action,
because I haven't been involved
with them for quite a while.
It's still an
organization of people.
And people do what people do.
And if different
people were involved,
you'd probably have
different actions taken.
Now, a lot of that takes
place in a context--
a political context,
budgetary context,
state of the world
context, and so forth.
But it seems to me
that they have never
been more open to really good
people going down and helping
out as I'm sure other parts
of the government are.
And if you have the right
kind of view and mentality
and capability, then
you have the ability
to actually change things.
And so rather than
a comment on the way
it is, I think the
more helpful thing is
to say, how can
we become involved
to change it to be more the
way we think it ought to be.
AUDIENCE: Well, in fact that
was kind of the comment,
is to generate a little
bit of discussion.
And perhaps some of
these people in this room
filter that back that direction.
I chat with Duane
Adams all the time.
[INAUDIBLE]
ENGELBART: I think that you
have to realize, those guys, who
they're between.
They have to go to a
new kind of Congress now
that's very different and
tough on this sort of stuff.
So they're not
But the whole general process
of the quick return and the way
it is an industry.
If your stock shifts a little
bit in the next three weeks,
that's bad.
So you can't do any long-term
changes that may say,
I'll drop for a while and
I'll make it up really later.
It's just isn't
allowable to the CEOs.
AUDIENCE: Okay, [INAUDIBLE]
[? Frankston, ?]
despite Microsoft.
I'm not going to defend Windows.
But what I want to
try to understand
is why Windows is such
a problem, in that--
if you have to change
the world all at once
and you can't coexist with what
exists, you've got a problem.
The web is a great example
of, independent of Windows,
it adds great function
and capability.
And there are lots of examples,
like Andy's Rollerblades.
People learning AutoCAD
or graphics systems
and interacting
are great examples
where people have
decided it's worth
investing major amounts
of time to learn
new paradigms and new systems.
It doesn't mean they
give up the rest.
What are you real
problems in getting--
do you really feel like to
change all the world at once,
or what are the problems
to get people to try out
pilots or new ideas in
industry or the world at large?
ENGELBART: The
only way I can see
is, you have to get
pilots operating.
And there has to be some
kind of conscious pursuit
of that future that you can't
really guarantee it as there.
But to say, look
at the potential.
AUDIENCE: I was
going to comment--
Notes was mentioned, and trying
to get people to adopt that
had similar barriers.
Again, far from perfect, but
it had a certain utility which
some people eventually found.
But I was just interested
in whether there
are any examples of
really sort of pilots
in that kind of new systems.
KAY: I don't think
it's worthwhile
commenting at length on it.
But I think my main point
is that I think MS-DOS got
millions of people used to, as
a normal mode of interaction,
to something that would have
been barfed at in the mid-'60s.
But they didn't know that
they could interact better
with a machine.
And so it really
set a low standard.
Just like television
sets a low standard
if you don't know
what theater can do.
You're never going to find
out by watching television.
That's the problem.
And so it's not that you can't
do other kinds of things.
But for instance, if
any of them-- let's
put Apple in there, as well.
Because from the standpoint
that we're talking about,
the Apple interface
isn't any better
than MS-DOS is and Windows.
They're basically part
and parcel of monolithic--
I think, for instance, if you
wanted to put an Engelbartian
scheme in your application,
in the Apple or Windows user
interface, it's almost
impossible to do.
Because the theory
of interaction
is buried so deeply in
there that you can't say,
okay, I want to interact
in a different way.
And yet in any reasonable
object-oriented implementation
of these things, as in fact
there was at Xerox PARC,
you could sit down and
design your own interactive.
In fact, NLS, which Doug
probably didn't mention,
had this interesting thing
where they actually--
you could drive the user--
in any part of the system,
you could make up a new user
interface if you
wanted to experiment.
They had this grammar-driven--
so you could put in an
interface grammar yourself
and use it to drive commands
if you were experimenting.
So it was what I would
think of as an open system.
It didn't force the user
to go just the way it did.
It was actually extensible in
some very interesting ways.
I probably have never
even shown that in a talk
because it's more complex
than the other stuff.
ENGELBART: Yeah,
it's interesting,
when he was telling us about the
emergence of Smalltalk there.
Well, what do you think
we've encapsulated that all?
And now that's going
to [? augment. ?]
And now we've got a Smalltalk
encapsulation package that
gives you a very flexible
kind of interfacing
that you can go conventional if
you want to that you can shift.
But anyway, I sort of
take my hat off to Alan
about providing the way
the Smalltalk [INAUDIBLE]
MODERATOR: Microphone.
PRESENTER 1: I get to listen
to a number of researchers--
MODERATOR: Turn the mic on.
PRESENTER 1: I get to listen
to a number of researchers
complain that the development
groups or the users in general
aren't willing to
adopt their ideas.
Sometimes I ask these people
to look at their own desk
and ask, how willing
are they to say,
I want to be the first user
on this floor of bubble memory
instead of magnetic disk?
I've just abandoned
the C compiler
because I just heard
about [? IFIL ?]
and I think it's really
wonderful and I want to try it.
I don't hear that very
often from people.
And they ought to accept the
idea that the rest of the world
thinks that they're not
different from the rest
of the world.
They're thinking the same way.
AUDIENCE: Samuel [? Ed ?]
Epstein with sensemedia.net.
Just kind of a setup here
and then the question-- and I
guess I'm young enough
to not totally believe
that there isn't any validity
to the conspiracy theory
that Ted was referring
to the other day.
And things are
pretty screwed up,
if you look at what was going
on 20 years ago and even
a little bit longer.
And I have to say that I've had
my own experience, like it was
mentioned earlier today,
about not being able to turn
in a laser-printed report.
The excuse that I was given
was because, well, the computer
wrote this.
And for this English class,
you have to write this.
[LAUGHTER]
And I have to say
that, when we're
looking at the big
picture here, I find that,
in my own personal
case and I know
there's others like me-- with
very few exceptions of actively
searching out the people that
are up on this stage here
and others like you, and
finding this knowledge
and trying to do
something with it.
The current educational
system in this country
seems to be doing a
really good job of helping
to create and accrete these
established self interests,
which seemed to prevent
the dissemination
of this information.
And also seem to
encourage this, well,
if it takes more
than five minutes
don't waste your time to
create this environment.
Do you have any
recommendations or suggestions
on how we can restructure,
improve, modify,
the established
educational system
so that access to the
information that you're
talking about is
available to people
that want to do things with it?
One of the things
that Alan mentioned
was, he held up in a slide
the book the Molecular Biology
of the Gene.
And I find this very funny.
If I had to name four
books that did it
for me, that basically
set my career,
the first one was Computer
Lib/Dream Machines.
The next one was the
Molecular Biology of the Gene.
The other two, which
I kind of do together
were Newman and Sproull
and Foley and van Dam.
The last one, which I
just read a few years ago,
which was a really good one,
was The Decline and Fall
of the American Programmer
by Edward Yourdon.
And this is also
really good reading.
But these are the
kinds of things
that have allowed me to
build up a career on this,
and other people, too,
often at the expense,
in spite or maybe despite
of their academic career.
How can we integrate
these things
together so that they don't
seem to be so conflicting?
KAY: Just a quickie is that--
just looking back, to
me, one of the paradoxes
is that I think we made a
complete mistake when we were
doing the interface at PARC.
Because we assumed that the kids
would need an easy interface,
because we're going to try and
teach them to program and stuff
like that.
But in fact, the
kids are the ones
that are willing to put
hours into getting really
expert at things.
They'll spend hours
shooting baskets.
learning to hit baseballs,
learning to ride bikes.
And now on video
games, the amount--
I have a four-year-old nephew
who is really incredible.
And he could use
NLS fantastically
if it were available.
He would be flying
through that stuff.
Because his whole thing is
to become part of the system
he's interacting with.
And so if I'd had
that perspective,
I would have designed a
completely different interface
for the kids, one in which
how you became expert
was much more apparent
than what I did.
So I'm sorry for what I did.
AUDIENCE: Let me rephrase
my question a little bit.
SPROULL: But wait, wait,
before you rephrase it,
let me point out--
you're stuck with it--
that Alan and Papert actually
did do a very wise thing,
which was to focus on kids.
Because not only do
they have the time
to learn weird and strange new
things, they love doing it.
And that counts for a lot.
NELSON: The design of media, as
soon as you establish premises,
you pretty much
lock it on track.
For example, the
time slot determines
the system we call television.
Once you have the time slot
and commercial television,
the rest is given.
Forget it.
Similarly, once you
have the curriculum
plus the implicit necessity of
keeping the dance cards of all
those teachers filled--
in other words, it's a system
for employment of teachers.
And so each teacher has
to have an excuse for what
he's doing all the time.
Then basically you have
the educational system
as we now know it.
As I heard your question, Sam--
and by the way, Sam and I
go back to when he was 12.
If I heard your question
correctly, you said,
how can we fix the educational
system as we now know it?
And of course, I think that's
a contradiction in terms.
The point is to get rid
of what is in the way,
and that is the curriculum.
And that is the guaranteed
employment for teachers.
Because that essentially is what
is in the way of the students.
If we could have a system,
for example, where you simply
say to a number of
14-year-olds-- right now,
we say to them,
you must sit here
for four years enduring
the duke of history,
the mistress of
mathematics, and whatever
you dislike about
them because they
will fix your point of view.
Education is a process of
ruining subjects for you.
And the last
subject to be ruined
determines your profession.
[LAUGHTER]
And each subject is
personified with the face
of this local ogre, or
perhaps, in some cases,
a wondrous person, who then
represents that subject.
And you never find out that
every subject has something
in it of interest to you.
Every subject can be something
that you take to your heart.
I thought I hated history, I
thought I hated mathematics,
because of the
people I encountered.
And so some other
way around, I would
like to see a school
system where you simply
say to the kids at
14, not, you have
to sit here for
four years enduring
and enduring and enduring and
being endangered and insulted.
But rather, you
can get out of here
as soon as you present
for examination any
of these 80 mini courses, any
80 of these 1,000 mini courses
on this sheet.
You can take more if
you want and learn more
before we send you out there.
Have your choice.
Then I think we would
see real motivation.
Because right now,
there is no way
students can
exercise initiative,
except A, if they're
male disobeying,
B, if they're female
getting pregnant,
and C, totally
obeying and outdoing
whatever the teacher wants,
which is done by very few.
Whereas, all systems
are based on initiative.
And if we give people a
way to learn by initiative,
then we'd fix the problem.
But nobody wants to do that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that was what
my question was more directed,
not at the technology, but at
the current system, and how can
we make it more conducive
to bringing people online
and getting the kids involved.
KAY: It's like,
cops need criminals.
so.
It's a very complex thing.
Seymour and I were in
Washington yesterday
morning talking to two
congressional committees
about the justice problem.
And of course, both of us
were conscious of the irony
that we were actually talking to
the people who were in business
to stay in business.
And so the interest in
changing things in any big way
was something that's
very, very far
from what they're trying to do.
For instance, the
average expenditure
for children in the US
is about $6,500 a year.
If you multiply that
out on a classroom,
you get to around $185,000
to $200,000 a classroom.
Well, those classrooms
are not receiving
anywhere near $185,000
or $200,000 a classroom.
From 1/2 to 3/4 is
soaked up by bureaucracy.
It never gets down to the school
or the kids or anything else.
And I think that is
an enormous problem.
And basically we said
exactly what you are saying.
The problem is that
there is a curriculum.
And we invoke the
name of Montessori,
whose idea was that
school should always
be an extended kindergarten.
And it's the job of the people
who designed the kindergarten
to make what happens
when you use it
for your own reasons
more interesting
than the regular world is.
And that's what Montessori did.
And I think that's an
excellent way of thinking
of designing a learning system.
NELSON: Do you know what
curriculum means in Latin?
KAY: Yes.
NELSON: Little racetrack.
PRESENTER 2: Ted,
you suggest basically
breaking the curriculum
up into small pieces.
And the Montessori
system, it allows
you to do whatever you like, so
long as, whichever Montessori
school, you use the same
colors for the same length
for the same blocks.
So you're put within a very
constrained world there.
And I think one of the things
I took out of your question,
which was clearly
a good question,
is, there are four books
which, for you, could
have been your education.
Given a computer, the
network, and those four books,
you would have been happy.
And you would have
achieved a lot of things
and wasted a lot less time.
AUDIENCE: And I was.
PRESENTER 2: Right, you were.
You managed to find them.
Question is, how can
other people find them?
For you, well, one of
the things you can say,
that should be a curriculum.
The reason that I feel that
the curriculum won't go away--
there's a neat
television program
in which the BBC took
four poor scientists who
had been denied acceptance
by the academic community.
Their papers hadn't
been published.
These beautiful ideas, wonderful
ideas were just outside.
They were just too
different and interesting.
And what they did, in
fact, was to show that,
by the end of the program,
that they were also total junk.
So the problem is that if you
don't have the curriculum,
then you leave somebody-- it's
like throwing somebody out
straight away.
You say, right, guys, you're
here to be free, to learn.
And here's the net.
And basically, they might
as well do that at home.
So you're really asking is
there a case from education
in the sense of
leading somebody.
Do you want to lead somebody?
Is there a sense
for having something
which is established as
being reasonable for people
to spend their formative
years studying.
And your problem
is that it takes
too long to get really
good ideas into that.
Now people are looking back at
things that Ted said, and said,
hey, that's cool.
That should be taught
really early on.
That should happen
sort of first grade.
But it's taken a long time
for people to do that.
And that's because it's
a filtration process.
That if you leave people to
look at all the information,
you also want to
lead them and say,
hey, this is really interesting.
And sometimes it seems that
the situations we've got,
just that the mechanism
we have for filtering
this and reviewing it
just takes generations.
Now, my only suggestion
if we're going
to change that filtrating
system, in some cases,
for example with computing, we
can move to a biological model.
So you can leave all your
programming people around.
And you let people
pursue projects.
And hey, you give
them CPU power,
and if they make something
which demonstrably works
and bubbles and
enthusiast people.
And now you've got the
net you can actually
use biological
methods, in some cases.
You can't do it for
learning good history.
But in some cases, you
can use biological methods
and get a faster turnaround,
because you can use computing
and a whole lot of
people out there
who will participate during
the hours of darkness
to try these things out.
ENGELBART: It just occurred to
me that giving its equal time
is not fair.
Because in the same amount of
time, he can say so much more.
[LAUGHTER]
KAY: That was the
problem with Butler.
PRESENTER 2: So many
words, so little time.
ENGELBART: I just want to say
that all these things are very
relevant to look out about
how you educate children
and that they can learn
more and differently.
But the thing is, that the
institution of education
does not like to be
changed by the children
to be changed by the people that
are there in the current state
in order to change it.
And we can't wait
for the 20 years
or so till those children are
out integrated into society
where they have the roles that
they can start making changes
that change driving things
about both world events, et
cetera, and the technology
are moving too fast.
So we're just
faced with the fact
we have to learn a better
way to shift organizations
with the people that
are in them now.
So that's really why you
need a strategy for it.
And it's exciting to think of
what the children can become
and to flourish, et cetera.
But the daunting problem that
I think we really have to face
is, how do you deal with the
change of the adult world?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
And also, thanks for
the last 20 years, guys.
AUDIENCE: My name is
Ricky Goldman-Segall--
I've met some of
you already before--
from the University
of British Columbia,
the faculty of Education.
But I'm not going to pursue
the issue of education,
because I so vehemently
disagree with some of the things
that you just said, Ted.
But you've heard my
story before with that.
Well, I remind you is
that, A, how many of us--
I guess, raise your hands.
How many of us
would have been here
if it weren't for one fabulous
or several fabulous people
in your life who
inspired you, and were
those people your
teachers, if they were?
I know they were for me.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Some of them were.
AUDIENCE: Some were.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's
not just the teachers,
but they had to perform
within a system.
NELSON: You mean
designated teachers--
a very important point.
AUDIENCE: Well, perhaps.
I'm going to respond
to Lee Sproulls notion
that science or
scientific investigation
is this relational and
interactive thing that actually
could happen in the
schools much more.
And I'm going to do that in
a way as a sort of summation,
perhaps, as well, because we're
at the end of the conference.
And what I'd like to
know is what each of you
learned from each other that
you didn't know before you
got here, and in some sense
what you think your biggest
similarities are.
But also, what do you think
your biggest differences are?
Because I think within
that, we sort of know
where some aspects of
the field are moving.
So I guess that's my question.
MODERATOR: We'll
start [? with you. ?]
KAY: Yes.
[LAUGHTER]
SPROULL: I learned that
Ted Nelson and I are alike
because we both
have purple socks.
I'm not wearing mine,
but he's wearing his.
And I learned that
Alan Kay actually
did believe that kids
would be working together
using their Dynabooks
over the network.
And I apologize, Alan.
I should have known that you
would have believed that.
I don't want to
be only facetious,
but that's a rather difficult
question to deal with.
So I think that
most importantly, I
wouldn't say I learned sort
of bits of information.
I experienced, I
guess, a reaffirmation
of the importance of the
ideas and the importance
of the scientists who
have been pursuing them,
sometimes with reward and
honor and sometimes without.
But that didn't
matter because it's
the ideas that were important
and continue to be important.
And so what was most important
for me was the reaffirmation
of that community.
NELSON: Well, I learned
that everybody here is
more idealistic than I thought.
Well, no, some people
couldn't be more idealistic.
KAY: I'm just glad to see all
these old characters still
hanging in there.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 2: I guess one
thing, which actually Vint Cerf
pointed out at a similar
sort of mix of people,
said that one thing that he
pointed out everybody had
in common was
persistence, having ideas,
and even though people
telling you not to do it,
hanging onto it and
being really stubborn.
And doing it even though
you're told not to
and even though nobody's giving
you money to do it and what
have you.
That seems to be something which
everybody has had in common.
I don't know whether it's
something intrinsic to us.
Or it's just that our ideas,
which once they've got you,
they don't let go.
Apart from that, I guess it's
pretty amazingly heterogeneous.
And the differences
are part of sort of--
and everything else.
Which is good.
ENGELBART: What am
I supposed to do?
If it's to say goodbye, well,
I enjoyed it thoroughly.
And it opens my eyes
to something that--
it was almost embarrassing.
It's that I sort of lost
track of a lot of things that
are going on that are
important and that I
wish I could keep track of.
So maybe I'll turn over
a new leaf or something,
or redivide my time differently.
But anyway, I
heard those remarks
about idealistic old farts.
And I thought, okay, that's
why I have to say something.
[LAUGHTER]
Anyway, thank you
for the meeting.
PRESENTER 1: There's
nothing to say after that.
I guess what I
thought I learned is,
once again, there's people who
are laying out broad visions,
and there are engineers
who are building guts.
And I'm led back to my
preference for the engineers.
And I'm glad to see
that Bush was one.
And I realize this is one
of the great engineering
institutions of the
world, and I thank it
for running the meeting.
MODERATOR: Sounds like a
good note to finish up on.
I'd like to thank our wonderful
speakers and the audience
for hanging in.
Sorry about that.
Sorry, Robert.
I'll promise to do better.
Oh, boy, don't like
to cross that guy.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to thank our wonderful
speakers and wonderful audience
for a really amazing
event in my life.
And I'd like to
invite any of you who
would like to hear Ted do a
reprise of his wonderful talk
of yesterday.
And for the rest of you,
godspeed, and see you
at the next one.
[APPLAUSE]